warning this site is for SCP personnel
with 05 approval access Beyond this
point for those with standard level four
security is prohibited and may result in
termination of foundation employment
unauthorized visitors who survived the
Mima kill agent are detained and
interrogated under truth exacting
mematic agents Dr Herman Wright was used
to high security protocols he had been
working with the SCP Foundation for
several years and had dealt with
specimens both terrifying and valuable
but something about this site was
different the security was tighter than
he'd ever seen and it all seemed a bit
too much for what looked like a
run-of-the-mill warehouse in Alexandria
Egypt the street seemed normal it was
surrounded by businesses selling food
and clothes and none of the locals
seemed to give a Second Glance but as
soon as he was approved for Access and
entered the warehouse it was a very
different story he looked into the
Cognito Hazard testing screen designed
to cause psychic damage to anyone who
hadn't been inoculated by the foundation
and now entered the large bunker
automated guns lined the walls he could
see the outlines of trap doors below him
and he was pretty sure the whole place
was rigged to blow if a large scale
assault hit the foundation was taking no
chance with whatever they had found in
Egypt what could they be keeping locked
up below as Dr Wright walked through the
long tunnel leading to the staircase he
could see a series of rules marked on
the wall no open Flames allowed with an
SCP
4001 no firearm arms or bladed weapons
allowed within SCP 40001 all writing
utensils brought into SCP 401 must be
approved by a majority of the 05 Council
violating these conditions could cause a
CK class restructuring scenario or an XK
Class end of the world scenario Dr wri's
mind raced as he entered the massive
antichamber and descended the staircase
but he wasn't prepared for what he saw
it was a library the biggest library he
had ever first seen with bookcases
stretched as far as the eye could see
the library was Far bigger than the
warehouse look from the outside and Dr
Wright assumed it must be a disguise
built on top of the much bigger older
facility that had been discovered by the
foundation it wouldn't be the first time
the foundation found something that
didn't conform to the laws of ukian
geometry SCP locations often played by
their own rules as Dr Wright exited the
staircase and walked up to the first
bookcase he could swear he heard
rustling sounds among the shelves was
something moving he hadn't seen anyone
walking the aisles when he descended the
staircase and he was pretty sure he was
alone here wasn't he making things
stranger a quick look at the bookcase
didn't show any books he was familiar
with none had standard titles in fact
they all seemed to follow a simple
format each title a different individual
person all books look the exact same
same binding same thickness same number
of pages was this some sort of SCP
reference library suddenly a hand
slapped down on Dr W's shoulder and his
heart nearly jumped out of his chest he
turned to see a gray-haired man in an
SCP lab code extending a hand to him Dr
whan Henrik Chief scientist in charge of
testing at SCP
401 you must be Dr Wright he didn't give
Dr Wright a chance to respond Dr Henrik
didn't seem like the kind of man to be
very interested in what others had to
say yes yes about time the foundation
sent me a new research assistant I
suppose you have a lot of questions Dr
Wright was supposed to be a researcher
not an assistant he didn't suppose it
would do any good to point that out when
Dr Wright tried to question what it was
that he'd be researching Dr Henrik told
him that it would be easier to show than
explain with that he motioned Dr Wright
to a nearby table where one of the
countless identical books on the shelves
was waiting he nodded at the book
prompting the the younger doctor to turn
it over and read the title he couldn't
believe what he saw there on the front
of the book was his name Herman Wright
Dr Wright looked at his colleague in
confusion and Dr Henrik motioned for him
to take a look it was written in a
language that he had never seen before
but was somehow instantly recognizable
and understandable and the book really
was about him every detail of his life
had been written down in this volume
starting with his birth containing Det
details that no one but he knew his
whole life story was here from his
childhood to his education to his
eventual recruitment by the SCP
Foundation but the book wasn't completed
the last line that had been written
described his entry into the secured
confines of SCP 401 that very day Dr
Henrik had a mad glint in his eye are
you starting to understand one for each
of us every person who has ever lived
roughly 120 billion people people since
the dawn of man their lives all written
down in these books every time someone
is born their book appears in this
library and their story gets written as
it happens the foundation has been
monitoring this site since the 1800s but
it's been operating much longer than
that since the dawn of recorded history
Dr henrik's past talk to write another
book it was simply titled the Hunter and
it chronicled the life of a prehistoric
man who spent his days searching for
Wild G game he lived 23 violent
monotonous years before his story ended
abruptly when the saber-tooth tiger
decided it was interested in the same
Mammoth he was hunting this must have
been one of the oldest books in the
library a book for every person on Earth
Dr R could only imagine what the scale
of this massive Library must be Dr
Henrik explained that mapping the
library was a huge challenge before
producing a map from his pocket and
laying it out on the desk you're at base
camp this is where new births generate
on the shelves along with books
pertaining to the first humans if you
want to drag down specific books you'll
need to know where you're going we've
established base camps around the
library to Mark significant errors in
human history with notable books at each
Camp you'll find generators supplies and
beacons to light your away if you're
going back far enough you could be
traveling for days or even weeks Dr wght
was fascinated by this bizarre location
containing the sum total of Human
Experience within its massively
expanding walls but there was one thing
he couldn't figure out just why was this
seemingly harmless location featuring
constantly changing books the most
securely guarded SCP he had ever
encountered Dr Henrik knew he was
referring to the extensive rules he had
must have seen as he entered the other
doctor reached into his pocket and said
let's just say that around here the pen
is migher than the sword he pressed the
pen into Dr wri's hand and flipped open
the back page of his book book it was
blank the rest of his story waiting to
be written what something you've always
wanted in your life Dr R think literally
why not put it in your book or remove
something you've always wanted gone
slowly Dr wri thought back to his
teenage years and recalled an injury
that he suffered in a mugging that
damaged his leg and left him with a limp
he nervously used the pen to scribble
out the words and sentences describing
the event after a few seconds he felt a
headache and suffered from a slight nose
bleed after that the limp and pain from
the injury was gone and he could no
longer recall the event you see Dr right
that's the secret of SCP
401 Dr Henrik said with a mad gleam in
his eye this Library doesn't just let us
read the history of humanity it lets us
write it that's why you're here to test
the limit of this power and see what
this Library can do for the foundation
Dr Henrik soon provided Dr Wright with
footage of some of the many tests
conducted in the library and what Dr wri
saw amazed him the books could rewrite
the laws of nature with alarming speed
as some unfortunate d-class Personnel
found out D
0546 was brought into a room with a full
head of hair the d-class Personnel was
instructed to scribble lost all hair
into his book and he soon started
scratching his head as he rapidly
started shedding hair after less than 2
minutes the man was completely bed d
0567 a young woman who had been brutally
injured when attacked by an escaping SCP
was bed written and would never walk
again according to all the foundation
doctors as the d-class Personnel used a
pen to scribble Over The Line in her
book describing her injury drct right
watch as she suffered a minor nose bleed
and then sat up getting out of bed as if
she had never been injured and no longer
remembered being attacked Dr CLA
Williams a foundation researcher sick
with cancer wrote Into the book about
curing her symptoms and then addressed
the camera explaining that this was her
third time altering her own book her
lymphoma symptoms had returned after
several months and 2 years respectively
but it seemed that as long as she
continued to make changes to her book
then she could keep the cancer at Bay
indefinitely but not all the tests ended
with positive results as Dr Wright moved
on to another selection of tapes labeled
mortality tests a d-class Personnel who
was given a fatal dose of drugs and then
had their death erased from their book
45 minutes later miraculously returned
to life but showed significant cognitive
deficits after another declass an older
woman killed in a Containment Breach had
her death erased from the book but came
back deeply Disturbed she survived 15
days in containment repeating send me
back let me go over and over again
before committing suicide a d-class
Personnel killed 28 days prior was
brought back by writing returned back to
life in their book but died again again
just 13 minutes later from a cerebral
hemorrhage but it was the next tape that
was the most disturbing it documented a
new book that was written by the
foundation depicting the life of a
fictional man down to the slightest
detail it was carefully placed in the
correct position in the archives
resembling all the other books and Dr
Wright watched the tape in amazement as
the man resembling the fictional
character created for the books
spontaneously generated in SCP
401 almost immediately the man started
vomiting blood and died less than 2
minutes later the book carefully
described all the things he died from
and stated that this was exactly as it
was supposed to be the fake book then
disappeared into the archives never to
be seen again the archive knew when it
was being used to play with life and
death and it didn't want any part of it
the next tape wasn't a test at all it
was a video interview showing a greeke
speaking scientist speaking with an
ancient looking old man found living in
the archives slowly after its Discovery
by the foundation the man who described
himself as The Watcher of Alexandria
Eternal believed he was keeping the
archiv safe from the Roman Empire and
the other Invaders He was unaware that
thousands of years had passed since his
watch began he had been using the books
to write himself another day of life and
to cure his ills ever since he began
guarding the library at the conclusion
of the interview he asked to leave and
this request was granted by the
foundation the ancient man died of old
age shortly after setting foot out of
the library while the library can't
technically cure death it does seem to
have nearly Limitless ability to prolong
life as long as someone is willing to
stay close by and never forgets to write
themselves another day where did this
incredible power come from an' 05
authorized investigation into the
origins of SCP 401 revealed that under
the archives carpet is a concrete floor
covered by a layer of Ash the ash was
carbon dated to between 70 and 80,000
years old in further analysis revealed
the ash is likely to be the remains of
burnt wood and paper despite there being
no known records within the archive
itself about a major fire having
occurred there Dr Wright didn't have
much time to dwell on the library's
great power of life because he was
suddenly shaken from his thoughts by the
sound of alarms was the library being
breached no it was Foundation officials
led by a man recognized as Dr Lincoln
Abrams the very man who assigned him to
this project
and he did not look happy he explained
that he knew what Dr Wayan Henri had
been up to writing in books changing the
lives of subordinance in an attempt to
play God he knew about everything of
course because he had read Dr henrik's
own book he knew all of the doctor
Secrets he knew everything no I'm so
close Dr Abrams I know I can crack the
archives rules there's a way to conquer
death here I can feel it Dr Abrams was
done listening and with a wave of his
hand Foundation security took Dr Henrik
into custody for a debriefing and likely
demotion Dr Abrams then turned his
attention to the new Young researcher Dr
Wright eventful first day I gather I'll
appoint a new lead scientist shortly but
until then don't disrupt anything
remember the archive is writing our
stories as we speak it's not very happy
with Dr Henrik make sure your story
turns out better and with that Dr Abrams
and his security team departed leaving
Dr Herman Wright alone with the endless
archives of Alexandria Eternal wondering
what would be written in his own tone as
the sound of new books popping into
existence filled the air with ominous
rustling it skitters in the dark its
insect-like legs tapping across the
marble floors as terrified Foundation
researchers flee they hear its voice the
Deep silky tones of an elderly British
man spouting nonsense likee the
nightmare is a dream to the nameless
slug that wanders across Minefield in
the remains of deer and Kings while the
scientists run the creature gains on
them it's fast impossibly fast while
they still try to escape down this
darkened hallway earsplitting
Containment Breach Sirens blast through
the air they may try to escape but it's
futile in a sense they're already dead
all they are now is Pray For The Heart
of Darkness when someone says the word
heart there are a lot of images that
come to mind you might think of
Valentine's Day heart-shaped cards and
candies you might think of heartbreak
rejection loss you might simply think of
a heart in the anatomical sense the
vital organ that pumps blood through our
bodies it's unlikely though that you
would associate the word heart with
Terror destruction and countless deaths
however employees of the SCP Foundation
might think differently especially if
they've ever had a runin with SCP
058 much of the information about 058
Discovery is highly classified but the
few details that are known paint a
chilling picture at an SCP Foundation
test site the day was proceeding as
usual with scientists and security
Personnel going about their regular
daily tasks there was no hint of danger
in the air beyond the base level that
always comes with setting foot in an SCP
Foundation site
at least several researchers were
performing an experiment the specifics
of which have been expunged from all
records involving the carcass of a cow
when a researcher Dr C placed his hands
on the specimen and prepared to dissect
it he was shocked to feel a pulse coming
from the supposedly dead animal Dr C
shared his surprise with his colleagues
but his concerns were dismissed
immediately clearly this was a corpse he
was imagining things they said after all
he was was relatively new to the job it
was probably just nerves the head
researcher Dr L insisted that he take
over pushing Dr C to the side Dr L began
to make an incision into the animal's
chest as he did he too felt something
peculiar there was no doubt about it
this dead cow had a beating heart he
looked up from his work to tell the
other researchers to explain what he
felt but by then it was too late
something horrible was all already
happening with a stomach churning sound
of squishing flesh the cow's heart burst
from its chest and flopped onto the
floor it was terrifyingly large and all
the doctors jump back from the side of
it four spinley spider-like legs poked
through the Flesh of the heart and it
began to quickly skitter about the room
researchers reviewing the security
footage would later note that it didn't
just move randomly it seemed agitated
angry at being discovered and it
displayed immediate hostility towards
the scientist s in the room four
tentacles next unfurled from within the
heart and stretched out into full ring
appendages they move frighteningly fast
as the heart whipped around the room and
were coated in sharp spines finally a
stinger poked out from the back of the
heart where the hole of the superior
venacava should be all of the scientists
leapt into action with one reaching for
a scalpel and another moving towards the
door but before the men could so much as
call for help the tentacles wrapped
around them and RI them to shreds
hearing screams coming from the
laboratory security Personnel arrived to
contain the threat however there were no
match for the strange creature that
would soon be known as SCP 058 it tore
through the security team in minutes
leaving their tattered remains in its
wake much to the horror of the surviving
Personnel at the site SCP 058 was able
to escape containment and make its way
to a neighboring Town reports of the
incident said that when the creature
reached the town you could hear the
screaming for Miles SCP 05a carved a
path of violence through the town
attacking everything in sight with its
stinger and tentacles and leaving a
trail of strange fluid from its stinger
dozens of citizens were killed and 70%
of the buildings were completely
destroyed when agents were dispatched to
the location to retrieve the creature
they were shocked to see the level of
Destruction caused by something so small
the scent of blood and smoke filled the
air and severed limbs littered the
ground alongside splintered wood and
collapsed brick the survivors removed
from the wreckage were inconsolable only
caling down once they were given an
amnestic to erase their memory of the
encounter with SCP 058 they had to be
given new lives as well as there was
nothing left of their old ones SCP
Foundation agents were only able to
capture and contain SCP 058 after it was
crushed by pieces of a building that
collapsed on top of of it they found it
flattened under a slab of stone legs
flailing uselessly tentacles limp the
agents were able to safely remove the
debris and bring in the heart without
any more casualties that day once it was
brought into captivity the heart was
contained for 3 weeks and remained
largely quiet during that time it was
almost inconceivable that this small
creature hadn't been killed in the
incident but the foundation would soon
learn that this creature was freakishly
durable
it escaped once more while being
transferred to an SCP Containment site
again causing injuries and death having
only experienced SCP 058 in its docile
injured form the team responsible for
the transfer was unprepared for the
sheer power and violence the creature
was capable of it was able to escape an
armored car and make its way into a
forest where it eviscerated several
squirrels and rabbits or rather they
were believed to be squirrels and
rabbits the remains were too mutilated
to properly identify it was only finally
apprehended after being crushed by an
armored tank but even this didn't killed
the creature and it was transferred to
Armed biocontainment Area 14 where it
remains to this day there is a great
deal about SCP 058 that is horrifying
but there is one attribute it has shown
in captivity that would make even the
most seasoned researchers skin crawl
though it has no anatomical capacity for
speech no throat local cords or even a
respiratory system SCP 058 speaks not
only does it speak but it speaks
constantly in the deep voice of an
elderly British man no one knows who the
voice might belong to or if it belongs
to anyone at all perhaps it belongs only
to SCP 058 somehow as is often the case
with scps that are capable of speech
there have been multiple attempts to
interview the creature and each time it
ended in complete disaster the only
interview with an available transcript
interview
0584 was conducted by Dr Johnston with
several Personnel in the room for
additional security Dr Johnston
attempted to get out the origins of the
creature asking for its name and where
it was from the creature responded in
cryptic unsettling poetry giving answers
to simple questions with I had dreams of
the queen Wonders that lived inside the
hearts of love and silence treatments
for all the elderly that I knew were one
whole after the fourth recitation of a
similar verse from the heart Personnel D
067 made a comment on the creepy nature
of its responses almost as if it was
offended by the remark SCP 058
immediately stretched a tentacle across
the room wrapped it around D 067 and
lifted him into the air he began
screaming and clawing at the tentacle in
an attempt to free himself as his fellow
Personnel tried to help him they grabbed
at the tentacle but found their hands
pierced and bloodied by the spikes that
cover it Dr Johnston commanded 058 to
let him go but it did not oblige instead
the man was crushed to death by the
tentacle and his limp body left to drop
to the floor the interview concluded
with a single statement from the
nightmarish heart the sensual violence
of lust is all the Assurance you will
ever need to know the worth of Life SCP
58 never seems to say anything that has
to do with the people or events around
it it speaks in the same haunting poetic
language even when it's attacking or
killing something no matter what happens
to it what is done to it or what anyone
says SCP 058 keeps talking and its tone
of voice with the pace of speech never
changing and further attempts to
interview it have been abandoned due to
the safety risk involved so what
happened to the creature often called
the Heart of Darkness where is it now
SCP 058 is kept in an isolated
containment chamber made of reinforced
heat resistant steel with a backing of
reinforced Concrete in order to Plate
its bloodthirsty carnivorous Tendencies
the creature is given a live cow every 3
days it is uncertain how exactly SCP 058
eats given that it does not have a mouth
or stomach but every time it is finished
with a cow only bones remain routine
maintenance is conducted on a tight
schedule and the heart is never allowed
out of its containment area under any
circumstances after two previous escapes
from containment the foundation is not
taking any chances its constant speech
is recorded via audio devices that are
running at all times out of concern for
their safety and mental health no
Personnel are permitted to listen to
recordings of SCP 058 speaking for more
than 30 minutes at a time it is unknown
what will happen to someone who listens
for long longer but it has been
suggested that the consequences could be
dire if the creature ever escapes again
the containment site is ordered to be
destroyed via the detonation of an
on-site nuclear weapon under no
circumstances can it be allowed to make
its way out into the world again even
with all these precautions in place SCP
058 has been responsible for over 150
deaths at its current containment site
there are some at the foundation who
have campaigned for SCP 058 to be ter it
believing that there is more harm than
good done by keeping it alive however
all attempts to terminate it have so far
failed no matter how much physical
trauma the heart suffers it does not
seem to be able to be killed it can only
be incapacitated for a short time there
is a classic Horror Story by Edgar Allen
Poe called The Telltale Heart in it a
man murders an old man and buries his
body beneath the floorboards of his home
there even though the old man is
certainly dead the murderer swears he
can hear the beating of the heart coming
up through the floorboards no matter
what he does to quiet the sound he
cannot Escape it and is eventually
driven mad by the incessant beating of
the dead man's heart SCP 058 may not be
a man's heart a human heart or even a
real heart at all however just like The
Telltale Heart it continues to
impossibly beat no matter how hard
anyone tries to stop it the steady thump
of its pulse haunts the SC P Foundation
a grim reminder that there is something
within its walls that can and will kill
everyone it can if given the chance it
couldn't be destroyed by collapsed
buildings an armored tank or an army of
experts and the contingency plan of a
nuclear blast is not even guaranteed to
work it is entirely possible that once
the facility has been laid waste and all
the staff have been incinerated and the
smoke has finally cleared the heart of
dark Darkness will still be there still
beating still talking and still killing
from gigantic indestructible
self-regenerating reptiles to enormous
tentacle telepathic organisms it should
come as no surprise that the SCP
Foundation has gone head-to-head against
a lot of large scale aggressors or lsas
in its time naturally a creature of
heighten size and aggression can often
prove challenging to contain and the
threat these lsas pose is often far too
big to ignore but anyone familiar with
the foundation will tell you they're not
above using any methods necessary to
keep these creatures contained huge Vats
of molecular acid impenetrable cells
disposable d-class Personnel even other
scps but what other scps could possibly
be big enough and tough enough to handle
some of the foundation's biggest and
baddest meet SCP
5514 otherwise known as as the dragon
slayer well it might sound like
something out of an anime SCP 5514 is a
massive robotic Mech designed to take on
the worst other scps can throw at it for
any who are unfamiliar with the term a
Mech or Mecca usually refers to an
upright standing machine or automaton
controlled by a human pilot what
distinguishes a Mech from a vehicle is
they're often humanoid shape standing by
petal and they are often hundreds of
meters tall all of this is cre of SCP
5514 and in fact given that it requires
a trained member of foundation staff to
operate it the mech itself requires very
little in the way of containment only
members of mobile task force ada5 are
trained and authorized to Pilot SCP
5514 this is one of the SCP Foundation
specialized units specifically designed
to deal with the threat of large scale
aggressors much like SCP 5514 itself but
SCP 5514 was wasn't discovered or
captured by the foundation for use for
the containment of lsas nor was it
stolen from a foreign military or found
buried under the ground then where did
it come from and who built it working
with the global occult Coalition and the
government of high Brazil an anomalous
island off the west coast of Ireland the
foundation themselves constructed SCP
5514 using various anomalous methods and
techniques in 1988 a foundation site was
destroyed ested by an unidentified LSA
highlighting the inadequacy of the
current defenses against these larger
more damage resistant creatures the
foundation the Coalition and high Brazil
formed a joint operation the key project
and examined SCP
246 an automaton 93 m tall thought to be
created by ancient mechanites together
the key project opted to create their
own similar machine viewing it as the
best way to defend against further
incursions with large scale aggressors
the construction of SCP 5514 began in
1990 the intention of all parties
involved in the key project including
the foundation was that the dragon
slayer would be deployed in the event of
an attack by an LSA it would arrive at
cities under attack and immediately
engaged large scale aggressors in combat
building of the mech continued at a
consistent pace for 8 years however it
was the occurrence of SCP
5391 and subsequent intervention by the
05 Council that accelerated the creation
of the Dragon Slayer by any means
necessary on June 30th 1998 a number of
seismic disturbances were detected
including tsunamis Tremors and volcanic
activity both underwater and above
ground What followed was the appearance
of multiple large scale aggressors which
would soon become designated as SCP
5391 the exact kind of scenario that the
dragon slayer was being built for had
already arrived and the mech was still
far from completion while the foundation
and its allies deployed forces to drive
the enormous creatures back to the ocean
something needed to be done to bring SCP
5514 into the fight and fast the 05
Council authorized the use of anomalous
materials in the continued construction
of the Dragon Slayer both to speed up
the process and have it ready for
deployment but also to give the mech
every advantage against the abundance of
large scale aggressors from SCP 5 391 as
a result SCP 5514 was designed to
incorporate features and Technology far
beyond that of any conventional military
grade weapons the first hurdle how do
you power a machine the size of SCP
5514 naturally with the most gigantic
nuclear furnace there is the sun more
specifically a perpetually stable
miniaturized Sun known as SCP
037 even though it only has a diameter
of 2 in
this little sucker is better than
premium fuel the surface temperature of
SCP 037 is around 5,000 Kelvin
generating plenty of energy to power the
SCP 5514 Mech stored in the dragon
slayer's chest this mini sun is kept
stable by subdimensional portals that
vent excess energy off this plane of
reality stopping the mech its pilot and
anything around it from melting in fact
SCP 037 produces so much juice that only
1% of its energy output is enough to
fully power SCP
5514 now that's the power source sorted
but how do you solve the weight problem
given the sheer size of SCP 5514 it
would be easy for it to be cumbersome
and potentially cause catastrophic
collateral damage to its surrounding
area well the mech weight is a problem
for somewhere else a whole other
dimension in fact much like the excess
heat from its power source various heavy
portions of the SCP 5514 Mech have their
weight shunted off to a tiny pocket
Dimension it was ensured during the
creation of the mech that this
alteration was perfectly calculated so
that SCP 5514 wouldn't lose any mass or
density so it operates as if it were
only a fraction of its actual weight of
course being weightless makes flight a
whole lot easier oh did we forget to
mention that SCP 5514 can fly as well
this feature actually became a part of
the mech completely by accident during
the constru ruction of SCP 5514 when an
attempt to regulate the mech's internal
circulation of air led to it having its
own gravity field this allowed SCP 5514
to fly without the aid of any turbines
or other means while this was an
unintentional mistake no attempt has
ever been made to correct for it for
fear that it could lead to SCP 5514
being grounded permanently naturally
going up against creatures so large that
they require their own subcategory means
that SCP 5514 needs an equally
formidable Arsenal so let's move on to
talk Weaponry mounted on the mech's
shoulder is a Beowolf sigur rail gun an
anomalous weapon that also doesn't obey
the laws of physics at all the Beowolf
sigur uses alternate gravity to affect
the weight of its targets causing
projectiles to impact with higher
velocity even the thickest skinned lsas
wouldn't want to be staring down the
barrel end of one of those big guns
aside the SCP 5 514 Mech also wields a
cold iron sword over 65 ft long this
weapon was contributed to the Dragon
Slayer by the high Brazil Royal Court
members of the collaborative key project
that created the mech sure a large scale
aggressor with thicker hide might take a
few extra swings to draw blood but it
will feel those swings for a long time
after since any wounds inflicted by the
cold iron sword will not regenerate
serving as less of an offensive weapon
the SCP 5514 Mech also features a unique
Armament known as the thousand-word
arrows as pretentious as it might sound
within the mech are seven poets their
role is to write and recite poems that
detailed the slaying of monsters and
these recitals are then broadcast from
the dragon slay on the surface this
seems to have no practical applications
during a fight with lsas however the
goal of the thousand-word arrows is a
form of psychological warfare the
recital of poems telling of the mech's
Victory and the defeat of large scale
aggressors is intended to have the
effect of demoralizing SCP 5514
adversaries while encouraging the pilot
during combat additionally warn a top
the head of the SCP 5514 Mech almost
like a hat is a discus with plasma Co
edges if the dragon slayer needs to deal
damage at range then it can hurl this
disc and recall it immediately thanks to
built-in electr magnets in emergency
scenarios if the cold iron sword is
damaged or dropped and irretrievable SCP
5514 is also equipped with an additional
melee weapon stored in the right arm of
the mech is a holdout plasma wrist blade
this superheated blade is strong enough
to cut through almost anything however
this blade is strictly to be used as a
backup weapon finally should all else
fail one of SCP 5514 greatest strengths
can also be used as a deadly weapon the
emergency Sun vent allows a fraction of
the Excess power from SCP 037 to be
released at the risk of causing massive
damage not only to lsas but to any
civilians or structures nearby it is
because of the destructive risk involved
that this weapon is only authorized to
be used as a final Resort and luckily
SCP 5514 is currently undefeated since
the arrival of multiple large-scale
aggressors as a result of SCP
5391 the SCP 5514 Mach has managed to
successfully eliminate 12 of these l LSA
creatures either by terminating or
otherwise incapacitating them given that
its completion was fast-tracked through
the use of anomalous elements SCP 5514
first combat deployments also served as
field tests of the mech operation and
the various weapons and features
arriving in Tokyo overseen by the
foundation's own Captain Rosalez and Dr
Kori SCP 551 14's first Target was a
creature designated LSA wake 02 as well
as several other unident identified
large creatures as the LSA was about to
attack Tokyo Harbor SCP 5514 was
dispatched it's arrival heralded by the
thousand-word arrows champion champion
exalt in the glory of the Dragon Slayer
The Poets recited surprisingly The
Poetry worked hearing it had a
noticeable effect on LSA wig 02 causing
the creature to back away shrieking with
a single throw of the rounded recoiling
plasma SCP 5514 immediately beheaded
wake 02 damaging a number of the other
nearby lsas as it retrieved the disc via
its electromagnets once again the
thousand-word arrows cheered on the mech
in the pilot reciting the vicious Beast
slain gone to those which were once Bane
after dispatching several of the minor
lsas with its cold iron sword SCP 5514
became aware that wake 02 was not fully
down for the count a second head had
protruded from the mouth of the
creatures first issuing some sort of
tree call to the remaining lsas in Tokyo
Harbor this second head then shot
towards SCP 5514 narrowly missing its
leg but allowing other lsas to close the
distance and prepare an attack luckily
the SCP 5514 Mech sword cleaved the
beast in two the mech began firing on
the remains of wake 02 with its Bale
wolf cured whale gun launching itself
into the air and flying towards the
target while bringing its cold iron
sword down through the air with a single
motion SCP 5 514 brought the blade all
the way down the lsa's body from the
creature's head to its coddle fin
gutting the large scale aggressor and
splitting its entire body in two after
one final squirm both halves were
finally still SCP 5514 had passed its
first field test the mech functioned
exactly as designed all its various
weapons and features working in tandem
to defeat a creature far too large and
Powerful for any conventional Force to
handle and thus the deed was done exalt
exalt in the glory of the Dragon Slayer
the thousand-word arrows called out as
the other lsas retreated one cannot help
but feel cautiously optimistic about our
chances of survival knowing that the
foundation has SCP 5514 as the first
line of defense against huge monstrous
beings that threaten Humanity as the
situation with SCP 5391 continues the
SCP 5514 Mech remains on the front line
standing between innocent human beings
and the looming shapes of multiple large
scale aggressors with creatures that
pose such a large scale threat it
certainly is lucky that disperate groups
were able to put aside their differences
and work together to build a large scale
Mech and because they did now we have
the dragon slayer on our side are you
sitting comfortably we know a good chair
is hard to find maybe you're watching
this on your phone while you ly in bed
or maybe you're watching at your desk
sitting in an office chair maybe you're
even watching it while you're in the
bathroom it's fine we're not here to
judge for our money you just can't beat
a nice classic wooden chair with soft
leather upholstery col us oldfashioned
but some things just never go out of
style take a chair like SCP 1609 for
example this fine piece of mahogany was
once a chair that simply couldn't be
beat in its quest to bring its user a
little dose of comfort and refinement in
their daily life tell us have you ever
been on your feet all day just walking
and walking and walking and at a certain
point you're just begging for a nice
comfy chair that'll let you take the
weight off your feet for a little while
you would have been SCP 1609s favorite
kind of person after all it was the only
chair that literally sought out weary
Travelers and even did you the courtesy
of tucking itself in that's not a
metaphor either SCP 6 1909 could
literally teleport to nearby people who
needed to sit down and didn't have a
chair to fulfill that desire it was
nothing but a nice helpful anomaly that
wanted to help people rest when they
needed it most the more observant
members of you have noticed that we've
been using the past 10 so far that's
because while SCP 1609 is still an
active anomaly it isn't a chair anymore
and this transformation wasn't something
that SCP 1609 planned anticipated or
even wanted the story of 1609
transformation even strikes to the core
of one of the foundation's oldest and
most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest it's the tale
of how a helpful piece of anomalous
Furniture became a paranoid killer but
first we need to talk about containment
procedures like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning
containment and specific containment
procedures are Concepts so integral to
the very existence of the SCP Foundation
that it is easy to overlook or forget
about them they're one of the Three core
pillars of the foundation's mission
statement secure contain protect because
of the centrality of containment to the
foundation's core principles one of the
most valuable roles on the SCP
Foundation payroll is that of the
containment specialist a vast team of
experts who work with researchers to
figure out the best way to keep every
anomaly contained based on their unique
unique abilities and attributes their
zookeepers archivists guards security
and intelligence experts magicians
practitioners of ritual scientists and
so much more in short they're anything
they need to be in order to adapt to the
ever evolving containment needs of the
anomalies they keep under lock and key
and containment isn't easy aside from
the rare safe class scps which require
incredibly minimal containment resources
the containment of most scps extracts
some kind of cost whether that be
Financial time effort or in some
particularly dark cases human life some
scps like SCP 974 and SCP
2845 require the sacrifice of human
children to prevent worse Fates
befalling many others other scps like
the infamous SCP 231 require the
foundation to do horrifying things to
the SCP itself to to prevent it from
manifesting some even more horrifying
anomalous traits and a third but equally
inconvenient kind of SCP like SCP 682
and SCP 076 require huge numbers of
heavily armed guards with powerful
weapons to keep their deadly prisoners
locked away often at a massive risk to
their own lives containment isn't easy
but it's ultimately the very thing that
makes the SCP Foundation the
organization it is if they were instead
of on a quest to kill and destroy every
anomaly they could get their hands on
then they'd be the global occult
Coalition the un's answer to the SCP
Foundation that prefers to seek disable
and Destroy rather than secure contain
and protect it's the primary
characteristic that differentiates these
two Titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows and right at the
heart of that difference is SCP 1609 as
we mentioned earlier SCP 1609 went
through a transformation that changed
everything but the SCP Foundation never
actually knew about the anomaly prior to
that transformation taking place it
first came to their attention when it
literally manifested within a
containment cell in storage site 08
making the rare move of willingly
submitting itself to the foundation
containment but what showed up in that
cell certainly wasn't a chair when 1609
appeared all it looked like was a pile
of trash specifically splinters wood
chippings Furniture nails and scraps of
bleached leather and fabric anything
that suddenly infiltrates a secure
Foundation containment site is caused
for concern even a bunch of wood scraps
so the site director sent in an armed
guard to investigate the mysterious pile
of debris researchers watching over a
surveillance feed were surprised when
the guard suddenly entered a state of
heightened distress he fell to his knees
coughing and spluttering until he
expelled a considerable amount of blood
from his mouth and nose he then
collapsed on the ground next to the pile
of debris dead an investigation
following this incident found that the
guard had died after a sudden influx of
jagged metal and wood had teleported
inside of him tearing his lungs apart
from the inside and causing the guard to
die a painful and horrific death
naturally the site Personnel were
somewhat concerned by this development
they sent in a d-class to investigate
further but we're surprised to find that
the d-class in question was somehow
completely fine the pile of debris that
would soon be designated SCP 1609 made
no attempt to harm the d-class as it had
the guard and finding out why this was
the case came as a side effect of
figuring out exactly what had happened
to SCP 16009 through a rigorous
investigation involving more than one
secret Foundation mole they discovered
that SCP 169 had previously been in the
possession of you guessed it the global
occult Coalition back then it was just a
help chair you once knew and loved until
the go had the bright idea of forcing it
into a wood chipper in order to destroy
it due to its connection to someone
called the carpenter but all the Go's
attempt actually succeeded in doing was
altering its form and completely
changing its personality to put it in
simple terms SCP 1609 is now a pile of
possibly cian teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case
of PTSD the incident with the wood
chipper traumatized SCP 1609 and its
anxiety is triggered by anything that
reminds it of the go or the wood chipper
incident this includes wearing formal
clothing lab coats protective clothing
jumpsuits and particularly body armor
but also includes anyone carrying
weapons appearing outwardly aggressive
using common gooc lingo or even
mentioning the go in SCP 1609 proximity
if any of this happens it's extremely
likely that SCP 1609 will resort to its
only natural defense mechanism which is
teleporting its debris into the lungs of
anyone it considers to be a threat the
guard had received this grizzly
punishment because his clothes weapon
and overall manner caused SCP 169 to
regard him as a threat and react
accordingly you may think this is
overkill on 1609 part but if you were
just trying to help out the chairless
people of the world then someone fed you
into a wood chipper you'd probably be a
little jumpy too since these early days
the foundation has learned to apply a
more Tender Touch when it comes to
dealing with SCP 16009 and the brilliant
containment Specialists even figured out
a way to keep 16009 happily contained by
placing it in a flower bed inside its
containment chamber where its wood ships
get to serve as mulch for a variety of
flowers and plants all attending
researchers and guards dress in plain
clothes and adopt a loose Pleasant
attitude while inside when whenever
they're around they make a point of
saying how beautiful the flower bed is
so that the disfigured anomaly that only
ever wanted to be helpful can still feel
like it's doing something nice because
of these containment procedures breaches
involving SCP 1609 have remained in the
single digits it is a perfect example of
less really being more when it comes to
containment the head researcher on the
SCP 1609 case Dr CT released an internal
document permanently affixed to the file
like a kind of cautionary signpost it's
a clear expression of exasperation and
rage at the actions of the global occult
Coalition reading SCP 1609 represents a
perfect example of the flaws inherent in
the operating procedure of the GOC and
serves as a cautionary tale for any
members of the foundation who disagree
with our practices on containing
dangerous objects prior to the Coalition
getting their hands on this it was
perfectly harmless a chair which
teleports to you when you need to see
seed is normal compared to most of the
stuff that we deal with on a regular
basis when they put it through a wood
chipper it got hurt scared and angry so
it lashed out at them by trying to
protect the World by destroying it they
inadvertently made the situation a whole
lot worse as CP 169 went from being
harmless to deadly in the space of a few
minutes because of the GOC and we had to
clean up the mess thankfully SCP 169 is
pretty simple for us to deal with so
long as we don't have to do anything
stupid around it it won't fight back and
it won't try to leave even if it does it
usually comes back and I think I've
worked out why it came to us because it
was afraid of the people who had heard
it that's why it always comes back it's
afraid of the rest of the world now and
it's looking to us for protection this
is why we have special containment
procedures instead of special
destruction procedures if you break
something it's broken forever when you
try to destroy an anomaly you can't take
back your mistake akes that's what SCP
1609 has to tell us this is why we're
right and the gooc is wrong people but
of course there are two sides to every
story and it's important to understand
the goc's perspective on this whole mess
to them this has never been SCP 1609
it's kte 0937 velvetine aka the 6th
chair it was labeled as the sixth
because for the go this chair was merely
one part of a wider investigation it
belonged to a six-piece furniture set
created by a dangerous anomalous Person
of Interest named the carpenter for a
classified customer the go was able to
intercept this deal and kill the
Carpenter and his customer in the
process after that all that was left was
to eliminate the anomalous objects and
five of them were incinerated without
incident however before they could do
the same to the sixth chair they
experienced an incinerator malfunction
rather than just waiting for the
incinerator to be fixed a member of GE
Personnel decided to rush the job and
run the chair through a wood chipper it
was at this point that its pieces first
lashed out invading the lungs of this
negligent go member along with five
others killing them all it was shortly
after that that SCP 1609 manifested in
Foundation containment much like Dr sver
did for the foundation assistant
director Kipling one of the goc's Legion
of middle managers a fixed a note to the
profile of kte 0937 velvetine that reads
kte 0937 velvetine is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper
operating procedures due to the lack of
vigilance by the agent on the scene the
object's Threat Level was escalated the
object itself was not successfully
disposed of and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency a single
failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six remember this next
time you think about cutting corners and
that's a good lesson for everyone
whether you're trying to destroy an
anomalous piece of furniture or keeping
its remains happy so they don't try to
kill you cutting Corners is always a
fast track to failure why do so many of
the indigenous cultures of the colder
regions of North America seem to share
the same Legend a legend that tells of a
monster that lurks in the forests
bringing cold and death to any that meet
it this creature is an omen of famine a
territorial Beast that prays on human
beings some cultures describe it as an
unh holy Abomination a spirit of winter
and a warning against the dangers of
selfishness one that is created whenever
a person resorts to cannibalism in order
to survive it will gladly devour any man
woman or child that wanders into its
territory holding a horrifying and
insatiable hunger for human flesh so how
did so many cultures end up with the
same story could it be because it's real
depictions of the Beast vary but it is
most commonly recognized by its tall
skeletal form like a body exuded from
the grave even carrying the stench of
death and Decay with it anyone who
encounters one risks being eaten or
transformed into a creature just like it
the monster's name means an evil spirit
that devours mankind though to even say
the name is taboo as it's believed to
give power to the Beast of course these
are all just Legends right stories to
warn against the dangers of greed and
selfishness but otherwise nothing to
fear there's no proof that such a beast
could actually be roaming the Frozen
waste many at the SCP Foundation felt
the same way until they heard about SCP
323 the wendo skull kept under lock and
key by the foundation with around
the-clock surveillance SCP 323 is an
anomalous object with ties to the
various wendigo Legends as the object's
moniker suggests SCP 323 is a skull not
a human skull mind you it more closely
resembles a cervid skull cervids are a
family of mammals that include most
varieties of deer elk and other similar
animals and this particular servid skull
Sports a tall pair of antlers SCP 323 is
definitely not a fresh skull either it
shows signs of weathering and a few
scars across the surface looking as if
the bone has been bleached and eroded
through exposure to the elements the
skull is also missing its lower jaw and
has a sizable hole on the rear Underside
that may have been carved using stone
tools SCP 323 is kept restrained inside
an armored container within a concrete
containment cell and Personnel are only
ever allowed near it to check the
restraints for signs of damage
additionally any foundation staff that
enter SCP 323 cell must be accompanied
by an armed security officer and in the
event of the containment breach the
entire site is to be evacuated seems
like a lot of precautions and safety
measures for an old piece of bone surely
a harmless deer skull could never be
that dangerous right wrong you might be
forgiven for thinking that a skull can't
possibly cause harm after all SC SCP 323
is just a skull then whatever animal it
belonged to is dead but this skull is
far more than it appears to be through
extensive testing the SCP foundation's
researchers have learn that the skull
isn't dead no this skull is awake and
awake air it can see hear and has a
sense of touch and it can and will react
to various stimuli however this does not
necessarily mean that SCP 323 is alive
or even sentient but it definitely
appears to have some level of sapience
it will Target certain members of
personnel that get too close and has
attempted multiple times to breach
containment it also reacts violently to
anyone speaking English or French near
it the only two languages prohibited
inside SCP 323 cell so while the skull
is not technically alive it is
definitely aware still why the need for
so many protocols to keep it contained
it's not as if a skull can just walk off
on its own of course not but SCP 323 can
move at least to a certain degree often
in a reactionary manner SCP 323 will
vibrate or move on its own for example
turning to watch's Personnel enter its
containment cell in most cases these
movements are tiny and insignificant but
other times the skull lunges launching
itself at Foundation personnel as it
desperately tries to get free now you
know why it's kept restrained so we have
an antler servid skull that can move and
has a low level of awareness on their
own these would be more than enough to
Warrant the foundation's interest but
the anomalous properties of SCP 323
don't stop there the skull has an
inherent ability to influence the minds
of those around it anyone spending an
hour within a 15 M radius of SCP 323 is
likely to experience the effects of this
influential power this will often result
in them exhibiting uncharacteristic
behaviors thoughts and urges including
cannibalistic Tendencies and outbursts
of random violence almost 3/4 of people
that suffer the influence of SCP 323
will feel an overwhelming compulsion to
take the Wendigo skull and fit their
heads into the chiseled hole on the rear
Underside if someone attempting this
finds that their head is too big to fit
inside the hollow skull there have been
cases of individuals trying to bludgeon
their heads on any hard surface they can
find nearby in an attempt to get their
head down to a more manageable size this
will continue until one of three
outcomes occurs one the person manages
to fit their head into the skull two
they cause themselves so much cranial
damage that they are rendered
unconscious or three they end up killing
themselves through repeated violent head
trauma of course if a person actually
manages to fit their head inside SCP 323
then that is a different story entirely
in these instances the individual
becomes classified as an instance of SCP
begins to fall out leaving them looking
starved and almost skeletal in
appearance they're distal fanges those
are the bones at the tip of the fingers
will elongate and rupture the skin as
they become bony claw-like
appendages the subject will also find
that their teeth have grown abnormally
long and sharp while their limbs will
blacken as if they were suffering
frostbite symptoms along with their
external Transformations SCP 3231 will
also get increased strength and
heightened resistance to pain they
aren't invulnerable though and can still
sustain damage and injuries SCP 323 will
also have a dramatic change happen to
their metabolism which will occur a few
minutes into the physical transformation
the subject will now need an almost
constant intake of calories which if
they don't receive will cause them to
starve almost instantly with the
transformation process complete the new
instance of SCP 3231 has finally become
the wendigo a terrifying monster with
one goal to feed the SCP 323 instance
will seek out any human beings it can
find so that it can feed upon their
flesh those who have witnessed the 323
instance in the midst of a Feeding
Frenzy have described the way it
violently slaughtered any person it
could find leaving only a mess of blood
as it devoured them their screams mixed
in with the sounds of Bones crunching in
the times that the creature cannot not
find a human to nourish its monstrous
appetite it will try to keep itself
alive any way it can sometimes it will
slow down its movement to try and
conserve energy other times it will
ration whatever food is available to it
saving some of its last meal for a
leftover snack and on occasion the
monster will engage in autocannibalism a
form of cannibalism that involves eating
parts of itself humans certainly seem to
be its preferred food source though even
when other sources of meat would be
easier to acquire SCP 3231 will Zero in
on human beings and will do anything it
can to make a person its next meal when
chasing down its prey human or otherwise
SCP
of the wendigo where do the phrases come
from though are they another side effect
of SCP 323s influence or do they
originate from the skull itself the
foundation's researchers are still
trying to figure that out and at the
moment they have no clues as to where
they come from in one Containment Breach
in 2006 during which an instance of SCP
3231 was able to kill and devour 12
members of foundation Personnel onsite
surveillance recorded audio of the
creatures speaking
hungry so
hungry it rasp while dragging a body
behind
it it oh
very always
hungry after this the sound of a wet
cracking noise was recorded possibly one
of the victim's bones being broken by
SCP
side the 3231 instance does at times
seem to try and resist the influence of
the wendigo skull additional recordings
capture the creature
saying the creature then said followed
by noises of it eating the
body it must must all
oh no to
no
so it seems that even the wendo has its
own internal struggles perhaps showing
that there is still something left of
the human who put on the skull and that
deep down they are fighting against
their cannibalistic impulses but where
exactly did the foundation find SCP 323
and is it really the skull of an actual
wendigo the famous creature from North
American Legend in 1997 the SCP
Foundation sent a Detachment to bitan
Lake in Saskatchewan Canada there had
been reports of a local community
murdering individuals and leaving their
bodies in the forest to appease a
dangerous creature residing nearby this
creature as it was later discovered was
an instance of SCP
3231 someone had found the skull and
succumbed to its influence BL in it on
their head and turning into a monster
ever since the locals had been killing
people and offering up their dead bodies
as sustenance fearful of what would
happen if they didn't after being
brought up with Legends of the wend too
SCP Foundation agents were able to
capture the Beast however died of
starvation while being transported back
to containment they also covered up the
recent deaths in the area by giving the
local residents amnestics and creating a
cover story about an unidentified serial
killer prior to this James namago a
local man who was involved in the
murders was brought in for questioning
he remained oddly calm when interviewed
but admitted he had helped move the
bodies that were being offered up as
food for SCP
3231 or as he called it the wendo
according to James a local story among
the cre people told of men who had once
tried to control a wendo and perhaps
even tame it through offerings of food
whether or not James and his fellow
locals had the same intention
their primary concern was keeping
themselves safe he described first
encountering the creature a warped man
walking out of the woods killed our
friends right in front of us sometimes
it would stare more than it would make
to kill try to talk to you it whispered
at me pisto come and eat it made me cold
in my bones as the interview continued
James claimed that he felt like he
understood this warped man he described
feeling like the windo was encouraging
him to kill that the creature would help
him pass when his own time came James
told the foundation doctor questioning
him that he had heard the creature in
his mind and he felt it watching him
almost constantly Mr namu stated that he
hoped in killing people as offerings to
the wendigo that his own family would be
spared like the other locals James
namago was given amnestics to forget all
about the creature and the murders he'
played a part in committing so far none
of the foundation's staff had have
experienced any similar behavioral
effects to those James described those
who work closely with SCP 323 or have
witnessed an instance of SCP
3231 have felt the creature
communicating with them or urging them
to kill on its behalf ultimately who is
to say if SCP 323 is the skull of a
wendigo like those from Legends it
certainly seems like it is but with no
way to tell exactly how old the skull is
perhaps it's actually the reverse and it
was the wendo legend that spawned from
instances of SCP 3231 that were first
encountered by indigenous North American
cultures hundreds of years ago one thing
is for certain if you ever come across a
skull with tall antlers you should try
to resist putting it on otherwise you
might not be feeling like yourself for
much longer climbers attempting to
summon Mount Everest and stand on the
top of the world have their work cut out
for them dangers are everywhere on the
long climb there's a risk of extreme
altitude sickness unpredictable winds
and freezing weather there's also the
threat of avalanches great Unstoppable
tidal waves of snow that can bury a
person alive in seconds or strand them
leaving them to freeze to death cold and
alone it's a sad reality that not
everyone that visits Everest comes back
down again and rarely does a climbing
season go by that the mountain doesn't
claim yet another victim situated on the
border between China and Nepal in a
subrange of the Himalayas of Tibet
Everest is one of the seven wonders of
the natural world with an elevation of
29,31 Ft or
8,848 M Mount Everest has attracted many
experienced mountain climbers over the
decades but even for the most
experienced Mountaineers the Ascension
up its snowy slopes is far from Easy
deaths occurring on Mount Everest are
nothing new and hundreds of people are
believed to have died attempting to
ascend the treacherous Peak sadly due to
the risks involved with carrying heavy
loads down off the mountain many of
those who die on Everest are doomed to
stay there forever their frozen bodies
serving up as their own grave markers
it's difficult enough to move your own
body up and down Everest and in many
situations bringing a body back down is
simply impossible the bodies of these
lost souls are scattered all across and
sometimes underneath the surface of
Mount Everest but some of those bodies
are different from the others and have a
special name within the files of the SCP
Foundation they call them SCP
5140 SCP 5140 is the designation given
to a number of frozen bodies which are
found all across Everest it is unclear
exactly how many instances of SCP 5140
there are though some estimates have
placed the number at somewhere between 1
and 200 at present it is unknown if all
the instances of SCP 5140 are dead
bodies belonging to climbers who met
tragedy on the tallest mountain in the
world or if some of them are something
else entirely but while their origin is
unclear if you come into contact with a
5140 instance there won't be any doubt
that it's different from the normal body
of a dead climber that's because SCP
5140 corpses are a lot like vampires in
some ways that isn't to say that they
actually are vampires they certainly are
not Undead and cannot function after
death but much like a vampire
traditionally drains blood to survive
these bodies drain heat SCP 5140 corpses
are ectoentropic meaning they do not
adhere to the normal laws of
thermodynamics whenever these cavers are
exposed to sources of heat including
human body heat the corpse will
instantly drain the source of any and
all thermal energy however the
temperature of these SCP 5140 bodies
remains the same regardless of how much
heat they are able to drain staying at a
constant 50° F or 10° C should any
living person come into direct contact
with one of the SCP 5140 corpses the
body will absorb their natural body heat
bringing their victim's own temperature
down to 10° C and causing them to die
and once they have died their body then
becomes a new instance of SCP 5140 as a
quick side note this might feel vaguely
reminiscent of another anomaly which
features seemingly inert dead bodies
that are hazardous to anyone around them
SCP 23 316 this anomaly is a powerful
mimetic Hazard consisting of a large
number of drowned human corpses these
corpses are extremely hazardous to
approach at even a considerable distance
as the mimetic hazard inherent to the
anomaly causes those affected to
recognize the bodies in the water as
people they know particularly from their
childhood like a siren Call the victims
are lured into the water believing that
the familiar bodies are calling to them
if the victims aren't stopped
quarantined and given amnestic treatment
they are essentially considered lost
they will walk into the water and be
absorbed into the collective becoming
just another body floating in the water
while the foundation doesn't currently
believe that there is any official
connection between the two anomalies the
similarities are undeniable and worth
taking into consideration moving on at
present it is unclear whether SCP 5140
corpses are caused by some sort of
infection or parasite that spreads among
the bodies uncovered at Mount Everest if
this is the case the foundation has yet
to uncover the patient zero the root
cause of these infected bodies there is
also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat as
well as how it achieves this and also
keeps its own temperature low but not
frozen given that interacting with an
instance of SCP 5140 can be fatal it
does seem that these anomalous
properties can be passed through contact
and exposure like a disease or par site
but there have been no observed
anomalous effects among any living
person visiting Mount Everest there is a
possibility that the SCP 5140 corpses
have developed some form of postumus
mutation that has come as a result of
being killed during an Everest avalanche
and buried in the snow their bodies
starved of heat after death after all
Everest is known for its cold
temperatures occasionally reaching as
low as 1° F or
-7° C not to mention the difference in
air pressure at such high altitudes as
well as frequent high-speed freezing
cold winds at the summit of Mount
Everest wind speeds can reach up to 280
kmph that is equivalent to 175 mph and
high-speed winds have even been known to
catch mountain climbers off guard and
send them plummeting to their deaths
perhaps the combination of these
conditions the freezing temperature the
air pressure and the winds have
triggered some sort of change in a
number of the bodies un forunate enough
to never leave the snow covered slopes
of Mount Everest either that or these
abandoned corpses left in such extreme
cold could be the perfect home maybe
some form of unknown and so far
undetected parasite is capable of
inhabiting these frozen bodies and can
spread to other living hosts by draining
them of their body heat stranger things
have certainly happened at the SCP
Foundation and that could possibly
explain why anyone interacting with an
SCP 5140 corpse meets the the same
Grizzly fate regardless of what causes
these abnormalities or why the SCP 5140
bodies have only been uncovered at Mount
Everest close contact with the corpses
often result in casualties and
fatalities naturally this is a cost the
SCP Foundation likes to avoid as often
as it can the nasty habit SCP 5140
corpses have of draining a person's body
heat makes it impractical to bring them
back to a foundation research facility
for testing as does the fact that
they're on the tallest mountain in the
world instead MTF Delta 14 have been
tasked with keeping these heat thirsty
cavers contained to Mount Everest mobile
task force Delta 14 also known under the
code name Winter Wonderland is formed of
a group of particularly Adept
Mountaineers and experts in
understanding and adapting to
particularly brutal terrain without
drawing attention to themselves these
covert operatives are tasked with
periodically climbing Mount Everest and
keeping SCP 5140 contained it is this
team's job to locate at any new instance
of SCP 5140 bodies and bury them in the
snow in doing so the goal is to prevent
any unwitting mountain climbers from
stumbling upon one of these bodies and
potentially becoming a new instance
themselves meanwhile the foundation is
pushing for both Nepal and Tibet to
tighten restrictions on climbing permits
but of course the money that Mount
Everest tourism brings to these two
countries has likely impeded this
according to the foundation file on SCP
5140 and an incident occurred during one
of mobile task force Delta 14's annual
Everest Expeditions members of MTF Delta
14 had been traversing towards the
Everest summit encountering more and
more of the SCP 5140 bodies as they made
their way up the mountain just as they
were instructed to do so the team buried
each of the Frozen corpses they came
across under a blanket of snow the Delta
14s noticed though that there had been a
much higher number of the frosty cavers
on this Mission speculating that perhaps
Mount Everest's high winds had blown the
the snow off of ones they had already
buried on previous missions one of the
Delta 14s a man named Charlie Smith was
in correspondence with his colleagues at
their base camp Charlie reported that
one of his fellow winter wonderlands
Patrick had touched one of the SCP 5140
corpses when the team reached the summit
and that he was now buried according to
protocols after becoming an SCP 5140
instance himself as they began their
descent from a top Everest Charlie sent
an urgent communication to base camp
reporting that uncovered three more SCP
5140 bodies at an abandoned campsite
except these three instances were
different from any he had encountered
before these corpses Were Somehow still
moving attempting to hurry down the
mountain Charlie reported that a massive
SCP 5140 corpses were blocking his path
and draining another one of his
squadmates Arnold of his body heat to
make him one of them Arnold had been
carrying the team's Provisions including
their oxygen reserves to combat the lack
of breath ible error at Mount Everest's
high altitude Charlie tried in vain to
use his flare gun to clear the path
hoping to distract the now walking
cadavers with a heat Source but it had
no effect his final message to base camp
warned the rest of Delta 14 to not come
to the summit of Everest with Charlie
frantically urging them to not let
climbers anywhere near it his final
message simply stated that the mountain
is danger a rescue division of mobile
task force Delta 14 arrived just under 2
hours later tracking Charlie's last
known location via a GPS Beacon
strangely despite the Frantic messages
from Charlie there were no signs of any
SCP 5140 instances none of the piles of
corpses he had warned them about could
be seen above the snow and certainly
none of them were moving it wasn't long
before the rescue team found Charlie
though he was dead but not drained of
heat or turned into another instance of
SCP 5140 no sadly after bringing their
fallen comrade back to base an autopsy
revealed that that Charlie had died
likely the same way so many other
Climbers on Everest had he had suffered
from a lack of oxygen further
examination of his gear revealed that
Charlie's oxygen intake valve had been
damaged earlier while the squad had been
climbing to the summit of Mount Everest
his teammates Arnold Hillary and Patrick
Edmund were also discovered on the
mountain but only Patrick had been
turned into an SCP 5140 instance Arnold
had simply died from exposure just like
Charlie the rescue team concluded that
due to lack of adequate oxygen Charlie
Smith had hallucinated the sight of SCP
5140 corpses moving and blocking his
path spending his final moments in
Terror as the Mountain's conditions
slowly killed him the foundation is
still unsure exactly what caused his
bodies to become instances of SCP 5140
or even how many of them are on Everest
but a major and troubling development
has recently been made after an increase
in global temperature led to a large
Avalanche that resulted in a large
portion of the mountain that had
previously been covered in thick snow
being exposed the foundation sent planes
that were equipped with thermal imaging
equipment to scan the mountain what they
found was as confusing as it was
terrifying the SCP 5140 corpses aren't
just spread across the surface of Mount
Everest they are much of Everest the
mountain itself is just a huge pile of
corpses just waiting to drain the life
from anyone who attempts to scale it and
turn them into a permanent part of the
peak so if you were planning a trip to
the Himalayas hoping to scratch clim
Mount Everest off your bucket list maybe
give it a pass otherwise you might find
that the climb is even colder than you
were expecting the SCP Foundation works
very hard to keep all the knowledge and
evidence of their discoveries from
reaching the outside world as far as the
average person is concerned the entities
and anomalies documented by the SCP
Foundation do not exist anyone that
stumbles upon an anomaly without
authorization will wind up having their
memory wiped with amnestics or something
far far worse but either way the
knowledge never enters into the general
Public's Consciousness but what if there
was an anomaly that even the members of
the foundation didn't know about not
because they hadn't discovered it yet
but because somehow it wouldn't let
itself be known it sounds impossible but
one particular Foundation researcher
faced this Paradox while covering an
anomaly that is currently listed in the
archives without a number referred only
as knife Junior researcher Harris was
assigned to SCP 4955 one day and given
the responsibility of examining it and
cataloging any anomalous Behavior
displayed by the item SCP 4955 was a
simple knife of unknown make and model
about the size and sharpness of a common
kitchen knife he took the knife into the
lab and ran the usual tests he scanned
the materials tested for any kind of
radiation administered thermodynamic
tests and did everything else that is
standard procedure for a new SCP in
spite of all of his efforts he found
nothing unusual about it at all it was
just a knife with a metal blade and a
wooden handle it didn't give off
radiation it didn't have any unusual
level of sharpness it didn't glow in the
dark by all accounts it was a completely
ordinary boring knife so why then was it
even at the foundation in the first
place why was his time which could be
better spent on other more pressing
research being wasted here junior
researcher hair decided to present his
highly uneventful report to his
supervisor it was then finally that the
strangeness began at the start of the
meeting Harris's supervisor had no
memory of anything being placed in
p0055 where the knife was being stored
Harris confirmed that yes there was
something there he continued his report
explaining that the knife had displayed
no anomalous properties at all and
didn't seem like the sort of thing the
foundation should be wasting resources
on as soon as he delivered his report
his supervisor just stared stared at him
blankly as if she was expecting
something from him unsettled Harris
asked her if she was all right she
replied sharply saying that she was
perfectly fine but was getting tired of
waiting for him to give his report
caught completely off guard Harris gave
her his report on the knife a second
time only to be met with the same Blank
Stare he attempted to give the report
two more times before giving up and
leaving an exasperation somehow as soon
as he told his supervisor about the
knife she forgot everything he said on
the subject determined to explore this
bizarre turn of events further Harris
set about recruiting a colleague to help
him conduct an experiment with the knife
he managed to bribe another Foundation
employee named researcher Smalls with $5
and the appeal of an unsolved mystery
and he agreed to step in and participate
as soon as Smalls entered the room where
the research was being conducted Harris
held up the knife and showed it to him
he asked Smalls do you see this to which
Smalls replied bafflingly see what
Harris approached Smalls Smalls holding
the knife right up to his face still
Smalls insisted that he saw nothing in
the room aside from Harris and himself
the more Harris pressed him the more
Smalls insisted with a smile that he did
not see the knife and had no idea what
Harris was talking about in a frustrated
Outburst Harris smacked Smalls across
the face with the broad side of the
knife he stumbled for a moment as the
blow made its impact then steadied
himself and looked at Harris with the
same expression as before the same
expression he had seen on his supervisor
earlier that same day attempting to
regain his composure Harris asked Smalls
did you feel that Smalls grinned at him
and replied all I feel is Bored
determined to push the limits of his
colleagues apparent forgetfulness Harris
cornered Smalls and raised the knife to
his face once more this time slowly
maintaining eye contact with him all the
while Harris used the blade to make a
deliberate shallow cut across smalls's
cheek the man winced as the knife made
its mark But as soon as the blade was
tucked into Harris's pocket in out of
sight he did not reference it once he
smirked at Harris with blood dripping
down his cheek from a wound he would not
acknowledge this experiment with Smalls
brought Harris's understanding of the
knife into sharp perspective the knife
itself was not the anomaly but rather
the knife's effect on anyone who
observed it everyone with the
inexplicable exception of Harris who
observed or learned about the knife was
rendered somehow unable to verbally
acknowledge or possibly even comprehend
its existence Harrison and Smalls met
for dinner later that evening and Harris
was fascinated to see that his
colleague's cheek was still smeared with
blood it had been left to dry there all
day undisturbed on smalls's face several
other researchers noticed the wound and
asked Smalls about it who insisted it
was nothing the Curious parties accepted
his answer but only after looking at
Harris for a long time though they would
not say it out loud on some level they
knew what had happened with the knife
when Smalls wasn't looking Harris dozed
his drink with a strong memory Recovery
Agent developed by the foundation's
antimemetics team and attempted to
introduce Smalls to the knife again
unfortunately it had no effect and
Smalls was still unable to acknowledge
the existence of the knife the next day
determined to take his experimentation
to the next level Harris cut his own
Chic with a knife he walked around the
facility as usual letting his wound
bleed freely onto his face and formerly
pristine white lab coat colleagues
stopped him to ask what had happened and
he told them plain
I cut myself with SCP
4955 upon hearing those words each
person asking about Harris's injury
immediately turned and walked away
covering their mouth believing the knife
to be some kind of anti-meme or an
anomaly that resists being recorded or
remembered Harris administered further
tests he ran the knife through a q&m
anti-em machine but found nothing the
knife behaved like previous anti-memes
but was unaffected by Machinery designed
to observe them and was immune to the
effects of memory recovery agents
designed to counter them what then was
it Harris was beginning to feel like he
was at the center of a grand practical
joke and he couldn't figure out the
punchline all he knew was that his grip
on reality was beginning to slip and the
knife was to blame Harris's supervisor
stopped by his office to check in with
him about SCP 4955 demanding a report on
the anomaly at the end of his rope he
responded what
4955 just as the supervisor began to
reprimand him for his poor attitude
Harris took the paperwork for 4955 and
shredded it into ribbons with a knife as
his supervisor watched as soon as he was
finished he looked up to see his
supervisor staring at him wide eyy
slowly she lifted her hand to her mouth
and began to laugh she laughed loudly
uously like it was the best joke she had
ever heard then she asked him to take a
look at s SCP 3309 instead Harris
clenched his jaw glared at her and
lifted the knif knife to his hand he
sliced open the tip of his finger and
flicked the blood onto her face she
didn't even Flinch instead she turned
away laughing face still streak with
Harris's blood and went about the rest
of her day this is the moment when
Harris began to crack all he wanted was
for someone anyone to acknowledge the
knife that was driving him out of his
mind it was as if the entire facility
including his own Machinery was
gaslighting him he decided to take more
extreme measures to get everybody's
attention at this point whatever it took
he would do it Harris marched into the
foundation's cafeteria at lunchtime
carrying his usual bag he walked into
the center of the room taking in the
sight of his colleagues his supervisor
still had his blood on her face small
still had a pool of dried blood on his
cheek from his day old wound Harris took
a deep breath and unzipped his bag
pulling out a test rat from one of the
Laboratories as the crowded cafeteria
looked on Harris pulled the knife from
his pocket and dispatched the rat with
one quick slash he held the dead rat up
in the air commanding the attention of
the room then let it drop with a
sickening thud no one said a word they
only watched and quietly laughed amongst
themselves 5 days later the Wrath was
still there it had been stepped on and
flattened by days of foot traffic flies
were beginning to buzz around the corpse
and the smell had seeped into the
ceiling and walls still no one mentioned
or referenced it no one moved it and no
one talked about the knife the following
day unable to stand the smell or the
sight of it anymore Harris broke down
and cleaned up the rat as he did he
could hear people laughing behind him
every time Harris entered a room people
were laughing about something and no one
would tell him what still when he
brought up the knife even when he
screamed and cried and pleaded everyone
ignored the subject it would not and
could not be spoken about several days
later Smalls complaint exped that
someone had cut the plants he was
growing in his room even though Harris
had not cut his plants he decided to
take credit I did it with my knife he
said as soon as the knife was mentioned
small sat down and went completely
silent abandoning the subject entirely
this gave Harris another crucial piece
of information on the nature of the
knife's effects it did not matter
whether the knife was actually present
or involved in something all that
mattered was the perception that it was
even the mention of the knife was enough
to invoke its effect the days bled into
each other day after day of Harris
begging his colleagues to see what he
saw demanding to know what the hell they
were laughing about and feeling more and
more utterly alone Harris's mind had
truly begun to come apart at the SCS in
the second to last entry in his research
log he simply wrote it's almost Showtime
time to give the people what they want
the day after he wrote that cryptic
entry Harris walked up to Smalls in the
cafeteria and tapped him on the shoulder
when small turned to greet his friend
Harris stabbed him in the chest Smalls
fell to the ground curling up in the
fetal position and Harris kicked the
knife deeper in as Smalls cowed there he
did not stop until Smalls was dead
Harris was removed from the facility
leaving the knife in smalls's body
Harris was promptly terminated
eliminating the last person who appeared
was able to discuss the knife as for the
knife now its current location is
unknown making this mundane little
object one of the greatest unsolved
Mysteries of the SCP Foundation what was
the knife exactly what gave it such a
strange hold on people in the end it
might not even matter after all what is
more frightening an object that prevents
people from being able to remember it or
being the only person in the whole world
who does an organization with as many
Secrets as the SCP Foundation requires
the ability to dispose of material that
could prove harmful to the facade of
normaly that the 05 Council desperately
wished es to uphold and because most of
the high ranking researchers are a bit
too smart and practical to Simply flush
classified documents and unwanted
objects down the toilet that means the
foundation has to get rid of evidence
thorough enough to guarantee that
absolutely no trace of what needs to be
disposed of survives for this purpose
several waste disposal plants are used
as front companies for the foundation
and function internally as a foolproof
way to liquidate hazard material and
comprising information but not all
secrets are so easily forgotten with the
push of a button and a rare few can
prove too resilient to be burned away
this is the regrettable case of the
anomalies contained within the site now
designated SCP
2419 a place where the unfortunate
consequence of amnestic experiments has
led to the creation of hateful Immortal
humanoids faded to be sealed within the
incinerator of the facility these Undead
freaks are known as SCP 2419 daa and
though they were made from human bodies
the Consciousness that dwells within
each instance is nothing short of Pure
Evil every happy memory and Associated
positive emotion was extracted from the
brains of SCP 24198 corpses prior to
their attempted disposal in the
incinerators this was done in order to
increase the effectiveness of standard
issue Foundation amnestics but the cost
of this minor breakthrough was that
these bodies all of which were once
d-class Personnel had effectively been
stripped of all human qualities given
the sorts of violent criminal
backgrounds that earns an individual the
designation of d-class personnel these
former humans were the last people that
should have been deprived of the love
and joy in their hearts and when the
first of these Psychopathic laughing men
crawled out of one of SC p2419
incinerators the foundation learned all
too well what an uninhibited Criminal
Mind looked like driven only by rage and
fury that inspired their most gruesome
acts of exploitation and violence in
life their pain has made them too
hateful to succumb to the Flames they
are the archetypal Sinners of a burning
hell that the foundation's best
intentions pave the road to and when
they break loose all that Hell Breaks
Loose with with them but no place of the
dam leaves its Gates unguarded Dante's
Inferno posits that the ancient Greek
mythological figure Minos Serpentine
father of the minor and judge of wicked
Souls guards the pit of Hell with Stern
vigilance the Greeks themselves favored
the image of Cerberus a three-headed
Hound that served its Lord Hades as a
watchdog for the ancient Egyptians there
was AMU the Devourer of the Dead who
consumed the hearts of the unrighteous
in the afterlife life while this sort of
guardian beast is not officially on the
foundation's payroll the concept turned
out to be alive and well in the present
day when SCP 682 the hard to destroy
reptile stood against the Laughing men
and gave them the fight of their
tortured unliving existence it all began
when the guards stationed at SCP 2419
began to hear banging from inside one of
the incinerators it seemed as though the
SCP
2419 instance on the other side was
determined to breach containment so
mobile task force beta 7 the MZ hats
were called in to stand with all weapons
at the ready but this was exactly what
the instance wanted as soon as the Armed
Force had fully assembled The Laughing
Man inside ripped the door from its
hinges it proceeded to use it as a cover
and run full speed towards the mobile
task force who opened fire immediately
SCP 2419 daa were known to possess
extremely fast regenerative abilities so
it would take a lot of punishment to
slow this instance down but this was no
unthinking zombie and the instance broke
its charge the second it was in the
midst of the mobile task force agents to
twirl the door around like a trained
martial artist this not only sent the
incoming bullets ricocheting everywhere
causing many of the beta 7 operatives to
be hit by their own friendly fire it
also allowed the instance to bludgeon
several agents with sides of the door as
the remaining mobile task force members
retreated to a exposed vantage point
where they could employ Heavy Artillery
the instance used this moment of
confusion to pitch the Door backwards
towards the incinerators in a boomerang
trajectory the force and spin of the
door knocked two more incinerator doors
off their hinges and caused two other
instances of SCP
2419 to emerge one who was so thoroughly
decomposed that it appeared to be more
than a flaming skeleton sprinted forth
and threw handfuls of hot Cinders at the
foundation agents it used its still
burning body to ignite a few of the
closest agents laughing with sadistic
Glee as it did so seconds after the
emergence of the two new instances a
grenade launcher was fired at the first
escapee the blast was enough to deal
significant damage but the instance was
indifferent to its own pain it pointed
to the agent wielding the grenade
launcher and a moment later the third
instance was at the agent's throat
strangling him to death it was starting
to become clear to the mobile T force
that this was no random Containment
Breach it was a coordinated escape
attempt by three ruthless criminal
masterminds who in their time contained
at the site SCP 2419 had probably
decided there was some truth to the old
adage that misery loves company and
indeed these three D class were some of
the best of the best when it came to
being the worst of the worst
d576 formerly police Lieutenant Campbell
farage a riot cop with a serious tap
taste for Carnage whenever the streets
of the city Precinct he presided over
turned violent farage always made sure
that the violence didn't die down too
quickly his nasty pension for
bludgeoning suspects and citizens alike
with his riot shield did wonders for the
Escape Plan he had coordinated with his
fellow laughing men he was eventually
tried and sent to a supermax after
picking a fight with several other
officers in the line of duty a fight
that resulted in a pair of rookie
officers who opposed his violent methods
being hospitalized with permanent Comas
the skeleton was D
4483 Damen Lambert a prolific arsonist
who terrorized Three Counties while
avoiding detection under the guise of
being a sovereign citizen if there was
ever a person who wanted just to watch
the world burn it was Damen Lambert he
was caught in the process of setting
fire to an elementary school and was
thankfully apprehended before any of the
kerosene he had poured through the Halls
ignited when the truth about his
previous history of Pyromania came out
Lambert faced death row until the
foundation chose to recruit him as
d-class then there was
d236 Arnold roer who was better known as
the Illinois Strangler responsible for
over 50 deaths in two decades before he
was arrested and detained while he
mostly used his bare hands to do the
deed rer was fond of using metal chains
and heavyduty choke collars usually worn
by animals to perform his name act of
violence roer wasn't just brutally
strong he was crafty too and the trio of
laughing men had him to thank for some
of the finer points of the Escape Plan
the three now Immortal d-class also had
one thing in common each of them had met
the ends of their cruel and violent
lives at the jaws and Claws of SCP 682
and now that they had outmaneuvered and
slaughtered mobile task force beta 7
their only Collective goal was to get
revenge on the monster that condemned
them all to the fiery hell of the
incinerator The Laughing men soon
breached the limits of the SCP 249
containment site and began making their
way Overland towards the facility where
all of them had met their original fate
they knew they needed Wheels to get
there so the instances made their way to
the nearest gas station from the waste
disposal plant they'd come from and made
short work of the staff Lambert stocked
up on lighters kerosene and Duraflame
while farage took the emergency shotgun
that the cashier hadn't had time to fire
in her defense it would have been
difficult to accomplish much of anything
with Roper's hands clasped around her
throat once the trio of Undead
Psychopaths had stocked up on weapons
they waited for a suitable vehicle to
pull into the lot and before long there
was a family SUV with a happy family
inside no less verage ordered Lambert to
keep his fire starting tendencies in
check as a gas station explosion was the
last thing they needed right now the
former riop made his way out to the car
and used the shotgun to threaten the
family out of the car family road trips
can be stressful but rarely does one
expect to be carjacked by a gang of the
undead verage told the Unlucky Mortals
that he wouldn't hurt them if they let
himself and his two friends use their
car and true to his word he didn't fire
a single shot the family were all added
to roer's list of victims instead after
that the three men took to the wheel and
with only their hazy memories of pain
and suffering to guide them drove
relentlessly towards the foundation
facility where their enemy SCP 682 was
contained the three had made sure to
leave no human alive at their original
containment site and would allow no
Witnesses who saw their anomalous
corpse-like forms to survive they
couldn't afford to give the foundation a
heads up that the Reckoning was on its
way in a family motor vehicle meanwhile
at the Laughing man's intended
destination SCP 682 was having another
perfectly routine day of painfully
soaking in a tank of corrosive acid this
was part for the course for the reptile
and it found itself as eager as anyone
else stuck in a rut to get a break from
the repetitive mundanity of containment
little did the human hating monster know
it would soon get its wish a few hours
later the facility was shocked to find
that several fires had been lit at the
fringes of the testing units these were
no freak accidents but rather the work
of Damen Lambert the arsonist still had
memories of all the times he wished he
could just burn his jailers buildings to
the ground and had targeted the most
vulnerable areas for combustion the
Flames threatened the Integrity of
several areas of the facility and
multiple containment breaches were
imminent if the blaze couldn't be kept
under control while any available agents
with firefighting experience sought to
minimize the damage the researchers
evacuated to safer parts of the building
bringing any sensitive documents and and
flammable items far away from the
affected sections this kind of
pandemonium was exactly where officer
farage thrived and he soon entered The
Fray causing enough commotion that roer
was able to slip deeper into the
facility completely undetected this
turned out to be the perfect role for
the Strangler as he hadn't eluded the
police for 20 years of his life just by
being lucky farage and Lambert would
both join up with him after they were
finished having their fun for now his
task was to locate the container unit of
SCP 682 and give the Beast a taste of
what the trio had in store along the way
he made sure to obtain some durable
metal chains from a different
containment unit he likely released some
kind of Elder evil in the process but
roer didn't care about the consequences
the bottom line was that he was always
able to do his best work when he was
armed it wasn't long before he found the
large chamber which housed his most
hated foe SCP 682 rer laughed maniacally
as he approached the creature floating
in its acid tank remember me lizard the
Strangler said sporting a wide grin The
Monster simply growled back at rer
wishing to tear him apart rer chuckled
again and wrapped the iron chains around
the vat with all the considerable
strength of his Immortal muscles the
Strangler pulled the chains taut and
shattered 682s containment unit the
anomalous chain snared the creature's
body holding it in place how about now
Robert taunted 682 he laughed but the
creature laughed back no said the
reptile I don't you but you are
disgusting the monster lunged towards a
nearby wall and burst through dragging
rer along with it by his chains still
wrapped around the creature's body 682
twisted and turned flinging rer against
every wall and obstacle in sight but to
its surprise The Stranger was
regenerating Ing and his grip on the
chains was unyielding back down the hall
farage was still continuing his Rampage
when he ran into an unlikely adversary
Dr altto kleff stood between the
Laughing Man and the other researchers
and as usual the good doctor was packing
heat he told the other researchers to go
on without him while he contained the
SCP 2419 instance on his own a bold move
to be sure but Dr kleff had made the
same mistake he was always making by
assuming that guns were the solution to
this problem farage laughed off the
bullets and slammed into Dr cleff with
enough Force to leave a crater in the
wall behind him he followed up with a
merciless barrage of punches beating the
armed researcher senseless and only
relenting for a moment to steal a few of
his prized Firearms with a blow that
would have taken the life of any normal
man farage struck Dr kleff once more and
left him lying there a hair's length
from Death Dr clef's anti- anomaly field
may have protected him from from reality
warpers but it did very little against
being kicked repeatedly very hard in the
face elsewhere Lambert had made his way
into the facility setting more fires as
he went the arsonist skeleton was a
terrifying sight to all that beheld it
and when the guards realized that none
of their weapons would have any effect
most of them started to run away from
Lambert rather than towards him all
three laughing men would soon be upon
682 and then the fight of their after
lives could TR begin until that moment
roer was buying his Partners in hatred
more time the chains he had stolen were
no ordinary metal and with them he had
managed to keep 682s Jaws shut while he
pounded away at its exposed ribs with
his inhuman strength rer had killed more
people than either of his former d-class
compatriots but all that seemed to mean
nothing in the face of this invincible
reptile the shame and powerlessness he
had once felt as the creature had mauled
him to death made his Immortal heart
beat without outrage when he was alive
the Illinois stranger had always thought
that his gift for murder made him better
than the average person A man among men
but this thing had made him feel weak in
his last moments of humanity and that
sickening emotion of weakness was still
sliding around in his soul with all of
the other Despair and Malice if his fate
were to live forever as a dead man
walking then he would make damn sure
that any humiliation he suffered would
be paid back three-fold this soup of
impotent Fury bubbled within rer as SCP
682 strength suddenly increased
shattering the weak link of the chains
and sending the hapless Strangler flying
backwards at that precise moment farage
leaped out of a nearby hallway and
Unleashed Dr clef's Arsenal on the
reptile this sustained fire irritated
the creature and it turned its focus
towards the unliving dirty cop it Reed a
charge only to be suddenly held fast by
Roper who had grabbed its tail barrage
fired until there was no more ammo then
pistol whipped the creature in both of
its eye sockets SCP 682 thrashed and
struggled so the men began to circle the
reptile and Alternate delivering
formidable body blows they took far more
damage than they could dish out with
their bare hands but the Regeneration
that their pratal hatred granted them
meant that both instances could
theoretically keep this up all day rer
grabbed a broken length of the anomalous
chain while farage picked up a metal
table to use as a makeshift riot shield
the beat down continued as 682s eyes
regenerated along with several new
sensory organs to give it a full 360°
view of the pitched brawl that was
taking place a fiery explosion blew open
a nearby wall and inw walked Lambert
still skeletal and laughing as
uproariously as ever he threw a Molotov
cocktail at 682s back causing the
creature to ignite immediately the
reptile roared in sudden Agony verage
Lambert Roper regrouped at the
creature's flank and pushed together
until they forced it back through the
hole where the arsonist had entered from
they were now all together in The
Inferno the three laughing men who
refused to die and the indestructible
monster that made them into what they
were Roper quickly nodded the chains and
wrapped them around one of the creatures
claws securing the other end around his
waist like a trained boxer he bobbed and
weaved pummeling the Beast with all he
had any step back from SCP 682 was met
with the immortal man shifting his
entire body weight to pull the
creature's leg out from under it barage
wedged his shield into the creature's
Open Jaw widening it to an uncomfortable
degree and temporarily limiting 682s
bite force he took out the shotgun that
he had stolen from the gas station and
blasted it down the reptile gullet when
that plan had run its course he started
clubbing 682 about its neck and head
with the butt of the shotgun Lambert
simply continued to dowe the arena with
more flammable material especially
himself and the creature he climbed on
to 682s back with his burning bones and
hammered away at its defenses with
literal fists of fire the arsonist was
incapable of articulate speech due to
the damage to his body prior to his
death but if he could speak he would
probably be celebrating the fact that he
had become what he had always wanted to
be Daman Lambert was no mere Pretender
with a fetish for fire he was F
itself a brightly burning God of
destruction that left no inch of the
world unburnt and no molecule of oxygen
unconsumed his mother and father would
be proud of him as they waited in hell
for the son who would never arrive the
son who had make the planet they left
behind into a true hell where he would
reign supreme that is until SCP 682
stole that dream out from under him with
a flash of blue and green from deep
within 682 began to burn with a neverbe
seen chemical reaction an impossible
event that could only be described as
anti-fire the turquoise anti Flames
devoured the orange and yellow ones
leaving Lambert in a state of panic
which was soon shared by his fellow
Laughing Man the three former DCL
classes had gotten so used to the
torments of the incinerator that the
idea that anything could be more painful
had never occurred to them and yet here
it was the anti-fire which devoured all
flames and directly inflicted
unimaginable suffering to the trio of
instances every particle of their still
regenerating bodies felt as if it were
ice cold and melting into nothingness at
the same time numbed and broken All Over
Again The Laughing men were consumed all
over by the anti flames and fell into a
state of suspended animation with the
foundation finally getting everything
back under control 24 hours later SCP
682 was contained in a new acidic
chamber there were some new ordinances
from all present and surviving
researchers about exposing it to fire as
the anti Flames It produced were
considered too hazardous to ever exist
within the facility again as for the
three laughing men who had escaped from
SCP 2419 they were returned to their
containment units inside of the
incinerators and never exhibited signs
of aggression or Escape attempts ever
again a psychological profile of forage
Lambert and Roper that all of them could
still feel the sting of the burns left
by 682s anti prior to this day and that
not even exposure to Natural heat and
fire could ever reduce that pain sirens
blared and the loud ringing of the
emergency alarm system gave everyone a
scare like something had jumped out at
them unexpectedly with that fright came
a sharp jolt of adrenaline something
wasn't right and their options were
either to await instructions or try and
flee with their lives most took the
ladder dropping their shovels and
various mining tools so they could turn
heel and Bolt to the nearest opening
outside if they could just get outside
above ground where the air was a little
clearer then they could avoid whatever
it was that was happening but for Yuri
Escape wasn't an option he had to do
something it had been a standard
operation everything had been run by the
books and was going all the smoother for
it but that Noble approach hadn't
stopped the drill from breaching into a
cavern carving through Stone into a
previously undiscovered area that on its
own wasn't enough to cause concern it
was the sudden caveen that had triggered
the alarms and led to the ensuing panic
at the controls of the gigantic
excavation machine Yuri helplessly
pulled at levers and press buttons
desperately trying to undo the rapidly
worsening damage but it was too late
rocks and debris were showering from
above like the Earth itself was
retaliating against the mining workers
it was as if they shouldn't have drilled
that deep the cave in almost like they
had awakened something unfortunately for
Yuri a falling slab of stone made sure
he wouldn't get to see exactly what the
dust settled shortly after but only one
recorded casualty along with multiple
injured mind workers wasn't enough to
deter them from exploring what they had
accidentally stumbled upon venturing
into the cavern system pierced by the
drill those who first dared to set foot
down there were greeted by the sight of
strange crudely built stone structures
someone had been here before but how
nothing could survive this far below
ground nothing living nothing human at
least and that was true given that the
workers also came across something else
in their initial exploration human
remains of course this raised quite a
concern prompting the workers to try and
contact their superiors uncovering
bodies wasn't exactly uncommon for
anyone whose job it was to dig into the
ground so they at least had a protocol
in place for this kind of situation what
none of them were prepared for however
was the fiery Abomination that suddenly
emerged as they were trying to call for
help the creature was a nightmarish
blend of a humanoid shape with the head
of a dog and giant Wings much like a
bats covered in rough fur its body was
exuding an oily flammable substance
which it used to incinerate the
surviving Mine Workers in an instant by
the time that operatives of the SCP
Foundation arrived on scene in the town
of M within the Saka Republic the
creature was on a rampage buildings were
collapsing as the winged Beast set the
nearby area of Blaze troops on the
ground even once they were able to get
the monster in Range found that their
Conventional Weapons were useless it
cost the lives of 17 mobile task force
operatives all ulated down to a cinder
before a chopper was able to neutralize
the creature with the threat destroyed
and the town administered with aestic
and fed a convincing cover story you'd
think that was case closed on a job well
done but the foundation discovered
within the nearby Miry mine something
that would completely change everything
they thought they knew deep underground
was a sinkhole leading to a spatial
anomaly below consisting of the system
of caverns that the Mine Workers had
inadvertently stumbled upon that wasn't
all that the foundation was about to
discover down there and what they came
across would soon become one of the
their darkest Secrets SCP
3667 it wasn't long before the
foundation began encountering other
unusual creatures that seemingly
appeared in the vicinity of SCP
3667 however not all of them match the
description of the original bat-winged
dog-headed pyromaniac visitor officially
dubbed as instances of SCP
36671 these creatures range from the
affir mention monstrosity to a whole
host of other strange descriptions one
was an abnormally thin humanoid creature
with reddish brown skin and a head that
was too big for its Ry body it possessed
an ordinary human level of intelligence
and even spoke modern Russian matching
the common local dialect in conversation
this being tried to offer wealth or
power in exchange for a person's most
valued possessions however it seemed to
possess no anomalous abilities and would
attempt to renegotiate a new offer
immediately after a bargain was made
then there were the magist Ates a group
of 48 humanoids with kyotic curv spines
all of them wore Furs and a variety of
skulls from animals such as Elks deer
and moose the foundation were still none
the wiser as to the true origin of all
these different subspecies of creatures
they were obviously emanating from the
sinkhole and the foundation had been
making use of MTF kai5 code named
Solomon seals to eliminate instances of
SCP
36671 that appeared From Below surface
to missile systems were even installed
nearby should any more flying creatures
appear but further exploration into the
sinkhole and the caverns below would
only yield further questions and even
more strange entities the four-person
unit MTF kai5 Team 1 was sent in to
conduct preliminary exploration into SCP
3667 to try and assess more accurately
the Threat Level posed by the sinkhole
and its bizarre residents finding
themselves in a large cave the team
followed the sounds of running water to
a wide stream the water a yellowish gray
in coloration they also detected the
sound of numerous Voices All whispering
in Russian but found it too difficult to
distinguish what they were saying there
were remains too of some kind of
structure that seemed to indicate the
existence of sentient life within SCP
3667 there was a portion of a wall even
a hallway that led into a large
windowless circular room the floor of
this chamber featured an elaborate
Mosaic that seemed to have sustained
some damage but strangely it depicted
anomalous creatures including some that
looked like the first winged monster
that had appeared after splitting up
down various corridors two members of
Team 1 encountered a new entity from
within SCP
3667 this creature resembled a large
feline but had no eyes and was about 10
m in height it referred to the MTF
operatives as Sinners and foolish
Mortals who should have stayed in their
cages despite being eyess the creature
observed that the team did not possess
what it called The Mark of Agana and
remarked that they should not have been
there feeling threatened by the creature
MTF kai5 Team 1 was able to blow it up
with a grenade before being safely
retrieved by their fellow Foundation
Personnel exploration into SCP 3667 was
then resumed by MTF kai5 teams 2 and
three who were alarmed to hear what
sounded like a human scream coming from
somewhere within the caves while they
first assumed it was another
36671 creature someone suggested the
possibility that a civilian could have
stumbled onto the site of the M mine
before the foundation had arrived and
established a secure perimeter around
the sinkhole hearing the scream a second
time this time further away the MTF
agents decided to investigate just in
case an innocent person had been dragged
underground by one of the creatures
passing through a basin of the same
strange fluid that Team 1 had discovered
the MTF teams could hear more unsettling
sounds coming from deep within the
caverns in particular a repetitive
scratching noise next they discovered a
large intricate wooden structure a
circle with one side that appeared to be
winched open inside they could see rows
of wooden spikes covered in a dark
liquid that everyone assumed was blood
hearing whimpers from their supposed
missing civilian the team's Commander
decided to call a retreat it was then
that the MTF realized there were over 20
more wooden structures nearby each was
of a different different shape and size
but all of them were covered in rats
that were staring at the foundation
operatives these various pieces of
wooden apparatuses seemed to resemble
torture devices and some of them had
bodies inside the MTF agents thought
they had discovered the grizzly fate of
their missing civilian little did they
know that things were far worse than
they first seemed the bodies and the
torture devices were still alive the
foundation soon realized there were
upwards of 12,000 people within SCP
3667 and immediately began efforts to
rescue as many as they could luckily
they had established a field base on
sight in the mine close enough to the
sinkhole that led into SCP
3667 however the unfortunate reality is
that saving all these trapped human
beings was no small undertaking and
space at their nearby base site 574 was
limited only 150 of the people were able
to be recovered and were transported to
site 574 those that were having been
found trying to escape from SCP
3667 or being eaten by the various
nightmarish creatures below but what
quickly became apparent was that these
people those safely recovered from SCP
3667 and those still trapped within
weren't exactly ordinary when Team 1 had
discovered the strange yellow gray
stream in SCP
3667 they had collected a sample of the
fluid for analysis examining this sample
revealed an anomalous molecular
structure that would actively bond with
organic matter and this same
unidentified molecule was present in the
bloodstream of the human beings found
beneath the sinkhole it seemed to have
bestowed each one of them with an
anomalous ability for a limited form of
regeneration their bodies could
withstand far more damage than an
average non-anomalous human the
foundation even experimented with
introducing the anomalous molecule into
the blood of other test subjects but it
didn't have the same regenerative effect
it was assumed that that the
Regeneration was linked directly to some
other factor and the molecule from the
fluid only acted as a catalyst as such
every person recovered from the caverns
was given the collective designation of
SCP
36672 now various subspecies of strange
creatures and a group of people whose
bodies could regenerate both living in a
system of caverns beneath M Saka
Republic not to mention all the wooden
torture devices that were being used on
the SCP
36672 chos just what the hell was going
on here and what was it that made this
discovery one of the foundation's
darkest secrets well the answers to that
could be discovered in what they learned
next about the anomalous people they had
recovered from the sinkhole as the
foundation continued its examination
their researchers at site 574 happened
upon a starting realization the SCP
36672 people were perfect physical and
genetic matches to former residents of
the nearby town of mney in fact of the
over 12,000 total only
1,328 didn't appear to correspond to any
known person from the area but then
thousands of others all had proof of
their existence that the foundation was
able to recover from the town's public
records dates of birth names former
places of residence family and next of
kin along with dates of death the SCP
36672 instances all claim to have spent
their entire lives under ground beneath
the sinkhole where they were tortured
endlessly by nightmarish creatures their
bodies could regenerate the external
damage they received meaning the torture
would go on for days months or even
years at a time when sampling bodies
buried in local cemeteries the
foundation discovered that these were in
fact copies of deceased residents but
not everyone who had lived and died in M
only those whose families had lived
there for at least two generations and
who while they were alive were suspected
of committing a crime but never
convicted there was one other unifying
Factor too during their lives these
residents all had some affiliation with
a particular religious group known as
the light of five Heavens Russian
Orthodox Church to put it simply SCP
3667 was hell following a number of
other incursions involving SCP 3667 D1
creatures the foundation was eventually
able to open negotiations with the
entities in order to Ure the continued
stability of SCP
3667 the former director of site 574
nidai bomi was appointed as the Director
of hell and placed in charge of
overseeing the anomaly under her watch
the foundation would supposedly be
relocating the displaced SCP 3667 d2s to
safe classified locations where they
could be reintegrated into society
however in an email from the director of
hell she proposed a solution to the
foundation st's dwindling number of
d-class personnel I am happy to announce
that something has come up that changes
that I'll be sending each of you a
shipment of new declass come next week
it isn't as many as you had hoped for
but rest assured these ones will
withstand most anything you throw at
them bodies all over the ground necks
Twisted faces contorted in Terror SCP
173 not one but an army scatters out
through site 19 massacring researchers
one broken neck at a time pure chaos how
could this possibly have happened the
strobing of the blood red emergency
lighting was already fear inducing
enough so was being hidden under one of
the tables in the mess hall trembling as
the noise of alarms rang out through the
facility but the thing about the
flickering lights scared SCP Foundation
researcher Mira Smithy all the more with
a few seconds of Darkness that came
between each flash of red if it had been
any other containment breach she
probably wouldn't have even noticed for
in those few seconds when the warning
light lit up only to cut out she
couldn't see a thing and her not being
able to see made it easier for them to
move around merera had lost track of
time since the alarms had first sounded
to Mark the Containment Breach she tried
to keep count of the minutes but the
drumming of her heartbeat had thrown her
off there was no way of knowing if it
had been hours or only a few minutes
since everything went wrong of course
the SC Foundation had plenty of
procedures and protocols in place to
prevent or respond to situations like
this yet the emergency alarms kept
echoing through the corridors lights
plunging the facility Into Darkness
every few seconds only to break it up
with a brief flash of red it seemed to
merera from her hiding spot that this
breach had proven far too much for the
foundation's extensive procedures to
counteract maybe it was all over already
she thought after a few seconds or maybe
minutes under the table table what if
they had gotten bored tired of
slaughtering their way through
Foundation personnel and slunk back to
their containment chamber that would
have been simpler far less terrifying
than the alternative that came creeping
into mea's head in the form of her next
thought what if she was the only one
left alive the last member of sight
Personnel still breathing just by some
random hundred to one chance and if that
was the case how long would it take for
them to find her
how many even were there a new sound
just detectable below the alarms broke
through her Avalanche of anxious
questions footsteps the noise of boots
clumping against the floor clearly
belonging to a human and not one of them
cautious as to which way her gaze was
directed mea poked her head from out
beneath the table glancing around during
the few seconds where the red of the
emergency lights allowed her to see the
steps were getting closer and as they
did researcher Smith realized something
that made her fearful for her fellow
Survivor they were running away and
there was no way they could do that
while also looking back at what was
coming after them over here she hissed
in a hush tone at the sight of a pair of
legs crossing a nearby Corridor their
thick standard issue military boots
seemed to match those worn by the
foundation's security Personnel the
officer passed by only to stop and
tiptoe closer to the mess hall having
heard Mira's whispered call with the red
lights blinking it looked like every
other step the security officer took had
been edited out like they were
teleporting closer in the dark watching
intently from her Hiding Place reminded
Mira sickeningly of the things she was
hiding from how they moved and the
worrying fact that she couldn't see one
following the security officer hello
hello called the man's voice as he
entered the mess hall under the table
mura whispered if we hide we can still
see them but they can't see us hiding he
replied no we need something that can
revert these things back to the original
it was so much easier to handle when
there was just one of them look let's
make a break for it I'm going to grab
SCP 3108 and get the lights back on if
we can restore visibility we might be
able to stand a fighting chance against
those things the officer was looking
around the cafeteria trying to locate
the source of researcher smithy's voice
eyes distracted then the intermittent
flickering of red light cut off again
plunging the entire mes Hall into near
pitch Darkness at the same time there
was the sound of something heavy and
stone scraping against the flooring it
turned Mira's stomach and she
immediately covered her mouth she had no
idea if they could hear her breathing
could a creature of stone even detect
sound at all well the lights were down
in the security guard's back was turned
a pair of sculptures built from concrete
and rebar traces of spray paint over
their Stone skin appeared behind the
officer at impossible speed there was a
sickening crunch followed by the sound
of something dropping to the floor of
the mes Hall as the emergency lights
flicked back on Mira could see them the
two copies of SCP 173 standing still
next to the table she was under bathed
in red light this nightmare had all
begun as an otherwise ordinary Friday
for the SCP Foundation only a few hours
earlier Mera had been brainstorming her
latest pitch for a series of experiments
involving SCP 914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks SCP 914 was a large machine
comprised of various cogs Gyros and
gears of Unknown Origin its function
however had long been documented and was
of great interest to the foundation any
object placed with an SCP 914s input
Booth could be transformed destroyed or
improved depending on the Clockworks is
setting Ruff would disintegrate the
subject course would dismantle it to its
base components and one to one would
merely replace the object with a similar
almost identical one then there were the
fine and very fine settings the former
would cause SCP 914 to improve any item
and the later is capable of the same but
with one key difference very fine would
refine an object even more usually by
giving it anomalous properties the
foundation hups had permitted staff to
freely conduct tests using the
Clockworks although approval was
required and all data was to be recorded
while many of the scientists at the
foundation were fixed on the mysterious
origin of SCP 914 or the furthest extent
of its refinement capabilities Myra had
been been thinking about it in a far
more practical way she wasn't interested
in the how or the why of SCP 914s inner
workings nor who had built it her
experiments were born out of considering
better usages for the Clockworks it was
a machine that could provide endless
possibilities and Myra was determined to
make it to the fullest use of it in
order to solve actual real world
problems imagine for a moment she
announced reading off her Q cards as she
practiced pitching her experiment to the
foundation's senior researchers imagine
a world where nobody ever gets sick
where human beings are able to live long
healthy and prosperous lives uh maybe
dial back on the Star Trek her colleague
research assistant Jensen interjected
really that's what you call constructive
criticism she retorted before continuing
if we apply the transformative
refinement powers of SCP 914 that world
could be the future that awaits us for
example I'm proposing tests that involve
placing man-made chemical compounds like
painkillers heart medication and other
potentially life-saving medicines
through the Clockwork refinement process
I'm not suggesting we need to set it to
very fine and create anomalous versions
of these things but what if even on the
fine setting we're able to improve the
effectiveness of our existing treatments
for all kinds of afflictions Jensen
raised their hand patiently waiting to
comment like a child in a classroom what
a few things they replied lowering their
hand first off some if not all man-made
medications include some kind kind of
organic component the 05 Council have
banned all yes I'm fully aware of the
containment procedures Mera interrupted
them that's exactly why I'm trying to
convince the council or how just even Dr
brigh to let me step around I genuinely
believe we could be doing so much more
with SCP 914 and I need them to see that
look I'm not here to r on your parade
Smithy her assistant reassured I'm only
bringing up concerns that anyone will
have about this proposal you talked
about wanting to improve our existing
Medical treatments which is Noble don't
get me wrong but have you considered the
wider effect that might have if you make
everyone on Earth more resistance or
even immune to everything then diseases
are going to evolve what if we end up
with a form of super bacteria resistant
to all forms of medication even if that
medicine's been refined in SCP 914
trying to save the world might just
bring about its end I've thought about
that but if the council starts allowing
for biological testing again then the
solution is obvious we use the
Clockworks to eradicate whatever germs
or diseases are able to develop after
improving treatment options Myra
explained then adding besides that can't
be any more dangerous than what we've
been using SCP 914 for I mean enhancing
other scps that's a recipe for disaster
got to agree with you there Jensen side
even without placing them in the
Clockworks the foundation's been way too
Cavalier with the Dangerous Ones
speaking of you know what tonight is
Smithy replied with a confused look date
night they stated elsewhere in the
facility unknown to researchers at that
time one of the dangerous scps Jensen
had mentioned had been let out of
containment this was a regular
occurrence even if it was considered a
little unorthodox to some in fact the
only reason that the 05 Council so often
turned a blind eye to it was because of
the researcher it involved Dr Alto cleff
it seemed cleff had a certain fondness
for SCP 173 the sculpture a living
statue constructed from concrete and
rebar that could travel at impossible
speeds whenever it was unobserved most
Friday nights clef would have romantic
candle it dinners with SCP 173 putting a
dress and blonde wig on the sculpture
and treating it like his beloved partner
the whole while watched by Dr clef and a
group of d-class acting as waiters and
Cooks SCP-173 would stand motionless
while the bizarre date went on late into
the night it was no secret that the
sculpture was a highly aggressive
creature with a pension for snapping the
neck of the nearest person the moment
that they blinked however it was only
because of Dr clef's reputation and
track record for the elimination of
anomalies that he was granted the
special privilege of whining and dining
with SCP 173 this time though partway
through their regularly scheduled date
Dr kleff was called away to deal with
matters relating to another anomaly he'd
been charged with decommissioning the
pair of d-class waiting on the doctor
and his date were instructed to wait
keep a close eye on SCP 173 alerting
each other in case they needed to Blink
it was a hell of a gamble a risk that
could have been avoided if the sculpture
had been transported back to its secure
containment chamber but Dr kleff could
be persuasive that is to say he
threatened both d-class Waiters with a
bludgeoning from his ukulele if they
didn't do as he asked both the DCL
classes stared directly at the sculpture
each one feeling the anxious beads of
sweat slowly crawling down their
foreheads worried that they'd both blink
at the same time by accident they
announced their need to refresh their
eyes every so often alternating between
being The Watcher and the one allowed to
Blink all the while as CP 173 was
motionless perhaps it was patiently
waiting for Dr kleff to return or for
one of the d-class watching to slip up
as if through some cruel twist of fate a
fly began to buzz through the air
drifting towards the d-class with their
eyes on SCP 173 it looped and darted
around its wings making an annoying
droning one of the waiters announced he
needed to Blink again and the other told
him he was free to do so while he kept
watch over the sculpture at the exact
same moment that one man blinked the fly
zipped its way towards the second DCL
class distracting him again and drawing
his gaze for a little more than a
millisecond that fly whizzing P was the
last thing he saw as SCP 173 darted
forward it moved with such incredible
speed that it was imperceptible grabbing
the nearby d-class the One who' spotted
the fly and killing him instantly before
the other could even open his eyes when
he did SCP 173 had vanished from its
spot at the date night table nowhere to
be seen before the remaining d-class
could realize it was behind him SCP 173
had made short work of its other
Observer it began zipping unseen through
the corridors of the SCP Foundation
facility Dr cleff had returned to his
date only to find the 2D class waiters
dead and SCP 173 missing immediately he
had raised the alarm meaning that
research staff were too busy fleeing to
safely pay any attention to the
sculpture quickly making its way through
the site swept up in the evacuation
sitation half deafened by the alarms in
all the commotion researcher Myra Smithy
hadn't even realized she left the door
to the Clockworks wide open shuffling
down a corridor with her fellow
researchers the lights suddenly went out
a few nearby screamed in panic at having
been unceremoniously thrust into the
dark Myra blindly reached for Jensen's
hand only to hear the sounds of multiple
heavy concrete feet dragging along the
floor suddenly the emergency lights
blinked she turned and to her horror she
saw SCP 173 with its Stony arms around
Jensen's neck their face stricken with
sheer Terror Tears in their eyes but now
Myra quickly realized as the corridor
was filled with shrieks of fear from the
other researchers that there was more
than one sculpture now Myra barely
managed to escape with her life in all
the confusion crawling out of the low
lit Corridor on her hands and knees with
the multiple new SCP 173 instances
slaughtered anyone that couldn't see
them since then she had been hiding
hearing the scraping steps of the
sculptures traveling around the facility
unobserved they had attacked the fuse
boxes first as if in a calculated
tactical move take out the lights and
suddenly everyone found it much harder
to see them even through the fear it was
hard for mea not to blame herself for
all the chaos she couldn't remember
whether she left the door to SCP 914
open or not but it hadn't taken her long
to figure out that the Clockworks had
something to do with this madness
somehow SCP 173 had made it it way there
had been able to operate the Machinery
while the foundation staff were
distracted by their own evacuation
presumably with SCP 914 set to very fine
the sculpture had been transformed into
its ultimate refined form or multiple
forms it seemed there was a veritable
horde of SCP 173s running a muuk through
the facility it made sense Myra reasoned
in some Twisted cruel anomalous way the
sculpture had only ever been a danger
when unobserved the second anyone took
their eyes off of it so much as blinked
it would strike how does a machine like
SCP 914 improve upon that easy it gives
the sculpture the power to replicate
itself anyone can look at multiple
things at once of course but nobody can
look at everything simultaneously even
if someone was watching a pair or three
SCP 173s one more could easily slip up
behind them for the kill still hidden
under the table Myra's eyes were locked
on the pair of sculptures in the ass
Hall the body of the security officer
out of focus in her peripheral vision
she dared not look away Frozen in sheer
fear that the second she blinked they
would lift up the table and find her she
had been so overwhelmed so paralyzed
with her Terror that she had forgotten
about the lights as the emergency
lighting flickered again the sculptures
both moved shifting across the mess hall
as the room went dark only to stop in
place the second Myra could see them
again they hadn't gotten closer in fact
both looked to be leaving
the only thing keeping them here was her
she was watching them and it had Frozen
them in place their greatest strength
the imperceptible movement and speed of
SCP 173 was offset by an indisputable
weakness of their anomalous biology they
couldn't stop someone from looking at
them and couldn't stop themselves
becoming still solid concrete when they
were being watched mulling over her
options Myra decided to follow through
with the plan from the Fallen security
guard to retrieve SCP 3108 and try to
undo what the Clockworks had done slowly
she slipped out from under the table
keeping both eyes on the pair of
sculptures keeping them lashed to one
spot as she gradually backed out of the
messall the lights went out and plunged
the area Into Darkness again and
researcher Smithy could hear the heavy
concrete scraping of the two sculptures
looking for her as she blindly made her
way through the facility she managed to
evade the roaming Stone creatures
resisting her natural in instinct to
hide and looking directly at any she
encountered on the way making sure to
stay out of their view if she saw them
she'd freeze them if they saw her they'd
chase her eventually fishing SCP 3108
out of a containment box Myra held the
weapon in her hand it was a heavily
modified Nerf gun which she loaded a
foam dart into and pulled the plastic
slide back the creatively named nerfing
gun had almost the opposite effect of
SCP 914 instead of improving something
SCP 310 I turned whatever was shot with
it into an inferior equivalent object
something worse than itself it just
might work drawing the gun as she heard
the sound of scraping concrete getting
nearer and nearer Myra turned the corner
coming face to face with one of the
sculptures she held the gun High closing
the gap between them making sure she
didn't miss but wary she needed to fire
before the lights blinked off again she
squeezed the plastic trigger sending the
foam darts shooting out of the barrel of
the nerfing gun the flimsy projectile
collided with the SCP 173 instance
bouncing off its head and landing on the
floor for a split second the light
stemmed again then came back on Myra's
heart had lurched in her chest only to
see that the sculpture hadn't moved at
all she leaned closer to it blinking
intentionally it still didn't move it
was rooted to the ground fixed just a
statue rendered powerless by the nerfing
gun excitedly Myra knelt down and
scrabbled on the floor to retrieve the
dart just as the emergency lighting
flickered out of again in her excitement
Myra was too focused on reloading as CP
3108 that is until she heard the
shuffling of concrete and rebar behind
her the lights were still out and she
fumbled blindly for the foam dart as the
noise got closer and closer her
fingertips brushed the projectile
knocking it further away when suddenly
the lights came back up but as she
reached for it researcher Smithy felt a
large cold presence behind her something
huge and heavy and made of stone and
lingering at the very corner of her eye
before she could turn around around and
face it something grabbed Myra and a
sickening snap rang out through the
corridor he had been pacing back and
forth all night so many hours spent
walking to and fro in his quarters that
his feet were starting to develop
painful blisters yet Jace couldn't bring
himself to stay still after his
unsettling Discovery over the course of
the night it had driven him almost mad
but it wasn't just the fear of the
inevitable Calamity he had learned of
that was keeping him up and worrying him
into state of near Insanity it was the
LIE the smoke screen that had been used
to cover up the truth and it came all
the way from the top Jace jacobe had
been working as a researcher within the
SCP Foundation for the better part of a
decade sure it wasn't an easy job at the
best of times in fact it could be dirty
dangerous and even downright deadly work
but Jace had learned to take comfort in
the bigger picture and it cultivated in
him a loyalty for the foundation and
what they stood for the reassuring
knowledge that he was playing but one
small part in protecting the world from
anomalous threats usually helped him
sleep a little easier at night this was
not one of those nights completely by
accident the researcher had learned of a
terrible truth he'd seen a lot of
horrible things while working at the
foundation from one horrific endlessly
regenerating omnicidal reptile to a
monstrous creature comprised primarily
of giant teeth protruding from its body
but what he had uncovered in the depths
of the SCP foundation's own archive
terrified him for a whole different
reason because it seemed to undo every
good thing Jace and all the other
Personnel had done in the name of the
foundation he believed that they were
the good guys that their efforts were to
prevent total Global destruction instead
it turned out that they were just pawns
being familiar with a whole filing
cabinets worth of special containment
procedures for various anomalies Jace
was familiar with the term 220 calabasis
he'd even almost been considered to
receive high enough security clearance
to be given the full details as to what
it entailed he was aware already that it
was the name given to a process that was
required to be performed by Foundation
staff as a way to keep SCP 2317 actively
contained SCP 2317 was a wooden door
leading to another dimension or at least
it appeared to be after accessing some
restricted files a suppressed secondary
level of information hidden underneath
the SCP 2317 entry Jace discovered what
was really going on SCP 2317 was in part
a door to another world as its nickname
suggested but that wasn't the whole
story Beyond the Door lay a Barren salt
plane the only structures visible for
Miles being seven identical Stone
pillars with ancient symbols carved into
their surface frequently a small group
of foundation personnel and security
staff would be sent into SCP
2317 each one of them given a specific
role to undertake as they performed 220
Calabasas that process required for
active containment was more like an
occultt ritual involving holy water an
obsidian edge knife chance that invoked
ancient powerful gods and a chicken to
act as a live sacrifice if Jace had just
learned those specifics of 220 calabases
he wouldn't have realized that the
ritual was actually a phony even a
pretty convincing one at that buried
beneath the pillars was chained
something of unspeakable unknowable
power it had gone by many names each
invoking a particularly nasty sense of
trepidation The Sire of tyranny kural or
simply the Devourer of Worlds the 220
Calabasas ritual was supposedly a way to
keep the Beast lock below to strengthen
the seven chains each latching the
ancient monstrosity to the pillars above
of except it didn't it was a smoke
screen the ritual did nothing to keep
the shackles of the devour intact there
was but one chain remaining one more
tether keeping the ancient Beast caged
and over the years no matter how many
times the foundation performed 220
Calabasas it was eroding getting weaker
and weaker it was inevitable the devour
of Worlds would one day be free and yet
that wasn't even the worst part about
what Jace had uncovered
what could possibly be worse than
learning an eldrich deity intent on
unfurling Doom couldn't be contained
with the one method the foundation had
well it was that the foundation knew and
had known for a long time that 220
Calabasas was nothing more than a
charade with all the effectiveness of a
Band-Aid over a broken leg as if that
wasn't bad enough Jace had traced the
source of this cover up right to the
very top to the highest operational
level within the SCP foundation's
hierarchy the 05 count Council was
responsible they had known for a long
long time about the ineffectiveness of
220 Calabasas and yet hadn't pursued any
more permanent solutions to the looming
threat posed by a SCP 2317 and the
Devourer after a sleepless night Jace
could hold it in no longer he had to
tread carefully given how far up the
chain this conspiracy went it was hard
to know who to trust something had to be
done that much was clear to him whether
that involves ceiling or outright
destroying SCP
2317 but if those tasked with overseeing
the entire Foundation were in on this
cover up then Jace had to be extremely
careful about who he went to for hell
there was only one person he was certain
he could rely on and share his findings
with in secrecy senior researcher Ellis
had long been a good friend of Jace's in
fact he'd even go so far as to say Ellis
was his only real friend within the
foundation the more experienced member
of personnel had practically mentored
jacobe from his earliest days as an SCP
researcher Ellis had helped him get to
grips with certain difficult containment
procedures and even taking the fall for
Jace after some of his early mistakes
nearly caused a Containment Breach
researcher Ellis's seniority meant he
only got away with a metaphorical slap
on the wrist but most crucially for Jace
right now Ellis wasn't a high enough
rank to be even close to any of the
upper echelon Foundation doctors like Dr
brgh or Dr gears nor was he seen enough
to have any direct dealings with the 05
Council if there was anyone working at
the foundation that Jay could possibly
confide in about his findings regarding
the truth behind SCP 2317 and 220
calabases it was Ellis and maybe between
them the pair could put their heads
together and avert the catastrophe of
the devour inevitable Escape Jace was
nervously pacing back and forth while
Ellis's eyes were glued to the terminal
in his quarters he had shown him a saved
copy of the full archive entry on SCP
2317 detailing everything not just the
steps required to perform 220 Calabasas
but the additional information about the
ritual not working and that the 05
Council knew it after a long painful
wait for researcher Ellis to scan
through the entire file he leaned back
from the terminal screen and sighed well
this is hardly ideal he stated matter
ofly hardly ideal Jace echoed his fear
of what all this meant manifesting
itself as a frustrated Outburst I think
you might be underestimating it a little
there Ellis this isn't just some mild
inconvenience we've now got to live with
we're talking about the end of the world
as we know it XK class and on top of
that the council knows it's coming and
are doing nothing about it instead
they're making these high clearance
Personnel go and pointlessly Slaughter
chickens and recite meaningless prayers
about Seven Seals Seven Rings seven
Thrones for the Scarlet King jacobe calm
down Ellis replied sternly let's talk
about this round Al for all we know this
file here could be a part of SCP 23
2017's containment procedures that's
what I'm saying the procedure is
ineffective he argued let me finish the
senior researcher responded calmly we
know of dozens of other anomalies that
employ infohazard or mimetic effects and
sometimes it's not uncommon for entities
of such nature with capabilities to
infect information itself to be combed
via the use of deliberate necessary
misinformation this file might not even
be an accurate description of SCP 2317
it could easily be a method for
containing something else no that
doesn't Jace paused holding his forehead
sorry all of this is giving me a
headache could I trouble you for some
water of course Ellis answered he got up
from his seat and filled a plastic cup
from a cooler in his quarters while his
back was turned jacobe didn't see Ellis
slip something into the water thanks
Ellis Jay said as he gulped down the
whole cup like I was saying that theory
of it being mic threat doesn't make
sense you've seen SC SCP 2317 from a
distance we both have it's a physical
dimensional Gateway I mean a door to
another world is literally its code name
for God's sake why would there be a real
door with an intangible infohazard
behind it Ellis stroked his chin
pondering quietly for a moment Jason's
Vision seemed to get a little blurry but
he blinked it away okay so if we take
everything in the SCP 2317 file is
Gospel then answer me this what do you
propose we do about it his mentor asked
we have to think radically together I
think you and I need to come up with an
alternate permanent solution to the
impending threat posed by a SCP 2317
then we present it to the 05 Council
store them into their chamber if
necessary and demand them to implement
it the next 220 calabases is scheduled
for a few hours from now we need to
bring them something that will actually
work not just that performative
pantomine they put on as a smoke screen
otherwise Alice Jace paused for a moment
hearing his own voice crack with despair
if we don't the devour is going to
destroy everything you said the words
permanent solution elaborate for me
please Ellis responded look I think we
have only two options the frightened
researcher said Jace noticed he was
starting to feel drowsy lightheaded even
needing to shake himself to stay upright
and conscious we either find a way to
Seal s CP 2317 or we destroy the door to
another world outright the 220 calabases
procedure that
no rual
ritual they take a one kiloton nuke in
with them in case of containment failure
right we detonate one of those inside
the dimension pray that it kills the
vour worlds then we shut the door and
blow blow that up behind to suddenly
Jace's legs gave out underneath him like
they couldn't support his body weight
anymore he landed on the floor with a
thud while Ellis loomed over him with a
sympathetic look on his lined
face
Dr me Jace barely managed to get the
question out I'm sorry jacobe Ellis
sighed believe me when I say I would
have preferred to talk you out of these
sedici thoughts but duty to the
foundation comes first you understand
the door opened theavy clumping of boots
against the floor Jay could barely turn
to see the squad of security guards
entering the room they lifted his body
up off the ground getting limper by the
second and began dragging him out by his
arms with all his waning strength he
kicked and thrashed his legs as they
trailed beneath him being taken away by
the guards Jace yelled for his mentor's
help he kept trying until his voice
became slurred imperceptible sounds not
even words anymore the world around him
started sinking into darkness as
whatever he'd been dosed with took full
effect as Jace was hauled off struggling
not once did Ellis dare to look him in
the eye Jace had no idea how much time
had passed only that he'd been
chemically knocked unconscious for most
of it opening his heavy eyelids he had
no idea where he was the room around him
was in Pitch Darkness for a second he'
wondered if he'd been executed by the
foundation and was currently dead his
Consciousness trapped in an endless Inky
void then another concerning thought
pushed its way into his head had they
thrown him into the devour of world's
prison it was a cruel callous move even
for the SCP Foundation to offer Jace up
as a sacrifice for daring to look
further into the truth behind SCP
2317 a column of light cut through the
dark from somewhere above him gleaming
down so bright that it was hard to look
directly at it the spotlight did little
to illuminate the rest of the room
although squinting in the dark the
researcher could detect the outlines of
several figures sat in a circle facing
him 13 of them to be exact with one
extra taking their seat he was just
awake enough to to remember a crucial
detail that explained where he was there
were 13 members of the 05 Council along
with one administrator hello again
researcher jacobe came a voice from one
of the seats encircling him tell us do
you know why you're here you Jay
stuttered before his fear once again
erupted in an explosive Outburst you all
knew about SCP 237 you had us perform
220 calabases time and time again
knowing that it was doing nothing to
keep the power contained if that
creature gets loose no when it does it
will destroy everything and everyone the
foundation is meant to contain anomalies
not pretend to we have a duty to every
adult child on this planet to protect
them from this entity do not exposits
the foundation's mandates to us shakobi
another of the council members voices
replied sounding not in the least bit
concerned if anything they sounded bored
the SCP Foundation acts in accordance
with what the council dictates not by
whatever moral framework you have chosen
to impose on this organization but the
devour of world is coming Jace pleaded
you all know as much I I've seen it in
the SCP 2317 file inevitable you used
that exact word we are aware of the
threat faced by SCP 2317 DK or the
devour as you called it a third council
member interjected but rest assured at
the time 220 calabases was established
to provide an illusion of containment we
calculated it would take decades for the
final chain holding the creature to give
way that time might have already elapsed
the researcher argued and in the
meantime we have no counter measures
prepared no strategy and the rest of the
Personnel have no idea that this threat
is coming huh almost exactly the same
wording as last time one council member
said not addressing the rest directly
but still just audible enough for Jace
to detect it what do you mean last time
yes thinking back a few short moments to
the beginning of this exchange wait what
why did you say hello again when I woke
woke up here there was a horrible
nauseating silence throughout the room
for a moment Jace had already worked out
the answer why would the council bother
telling him the truth now I've figured
this out before haven't I he said a
handful of times one of the voices
replied if not you then another member
of personnel every now and then someone
snoops uncovers something they shouldn't
and you make them forget it Jace
finishes their sentence for them before
we
applys the voice said obser
today's Tuton Cal's procedure is already
underway a huge curved screen blinked to
life it filled half the circumference of
the room but wasn't enough to give Jace
any clearer of a look at the 05 Council
each one of them was cast as shadowy
silhouetted figures against the images
now appearing on the screen it was
footage being streamed live from one of
the Personnel cleared to enter as CP
2317 they were already in the middle of
Performing the phony ritual spritzing
holy water over over the Seven Pillars
unaware that one of them was still
linked to a chain keeping the Devourer
imprison below suddenly there was a
rumbling a shaking reverberating through
the ground on the video feed like an
earthquake or something moving
underneath oh my God Jace breathed as he
watched in horror it's happening the
devour is coming now get them out of
there some of the 05s mumbled awkwardly
to themselves we shouldn't act with too
much haste it could just be the creature
reacting to the ritual one hypothesized
it's been imprison for a lot longer than
a lot of us have lived it's bound to get
Restless another concurred besides the
security team are armed with a nuclear
device in case the was should happen on
the screen the Tremors were continuing
the Personnel member in charge of
applying the holy water dropped the
silver aspergum and as sporum containing
it spilling its contents Over The Salted
earth below without any further warning
the ground started to crumble in the
feed an enormous clawed hand bursting up
from underground it was followed by the
hulking shape of something much larger
breaking through the salt plane sending
a tidal wave towards the Personnel
member whose body cam footage was being
displayed the feed cut out and the room
was dark once again it's too late Jay
stared at the council in a mix of Terror
and disgust you did nothing and now it's
too late before any of them could reply
another Tremor rang out this time
beneath Jace's own feet the devour of
Worlds was here it was bursting through
the wooden door of SCP 2317 and tearing
the found found ation facility aparted
with its immense size as it emerged the
walls cracked the entire building
beginning to crumble around him and the
05 Council who were all hurriedly
exiting the chamber to whatever plans or
bunkers they had to ensure their own
personal survival suddenly the huge
weight of something dropped through the
dark and collapsed on top of Jace
standing up amongst the wreckage of the
obliterated building the devour of
Worlds Drew itself up to its full height
it was an impossibly large creature
humanoid and obese its entire body was
covered head to toe in thick armored
scales with horns at top its jawless
head from one of them hung the final
chain a withered shackle no longer
keeping the monster held within its
underground prison the seven chains had
all failed the ritual 220 Calabasas had
failed in fact it never worked in the
first place far below his arms pinned
painfully under a heavy slab of concrete
Jay stared up at the Towering form of
the devour he had felt scared as the
building came down around him and even
now there was a lingering fear of his
own death but there was something else
there too a sense of feeling oddly
relieved not necessarily glad to be
right about the impending doom or even
pleased to know this ancient tra deity
was about to destroy the whole planet
but at least the devour of Worlds was
honest he thought there was no
subterfuge no rituals acting as a smoke
screen no more lies just and honest
Simplicity of a creature whose only goal
was to bring an end to everything as
Jace watched the devour raised its hands
up reaching the highest Pinnacle of the
sky then brought them straight back down
to earth it plunged both deep into the
skin of the world deep enough to crack
the very surface open mantle and magma
were spewing everywhere like blood from
the gaping wounds had left in the planet
Jace Jacobi closed his eyes as the
ground beneath where he lay trapped
ripped open plummeting him into the dark
stop R up folks we've got all kinds of
refreshing and tasty treats here for you
today popcorn peanuts cotton candy and
even fried dough Yer here at SCP
explained we're offering the Top ofthe
Line anomalous delectable food stuffs
for all your circus themed Funtime
occasions and that's because today yes
today on this YouTube platform our
Infamous acronym doesn't stand for
secure contained protect it stands for
sweet confectionary products and let me
tell you dear viewer the SCP we're
looking at today just might be the most
decadent durable and dangerous dessert
that's ever desired to be devoured we're
talking about SCP
377 or as they are better known the
sugar Golems these little fellas are
safe class and also totally harmless so
long as you take the proper precautions
what's the matter don't you believe me
don't you think it's nice of us to cover
a safe SCP now and again and hey now why
all this dull talk about rules and
regulations in the first place you don't
go out to the carnival to not take wild
and exciting risks every spinny twirly
and whirly ride on the fairgrounds comes
with a statistically higher chance of a
tragic mishap befalling you and any
other Thrill Seekers around you but we
all take that chance anyway for the
extraordinary Rush of the experience and
such is the wacky and wonderful ways of
our adorable and questionably edible
Chums the sugar Golems don't you just
love them folks ain't they a sight for
sore eyes and a pay for sweet teeth well
we're only just getting started The Best
Is Yet To Come ladies and ND ladies so
pull up a chair and be sure to watch
what we've got in store you can make
like a piece of old candy and stick
around now that's a knee slapper ain't
it sit back relax and make sure to enjoy
the show you should also subscribe to SC
SCP explain if you'd like to continue to
be entertained hey that rhy what do you
no I'm a boat and I didn't even know it
out roll while SCP 377 refers to the
anomalous substance contained in site 81
the semi-humanoid instances which are
nicknamed sugar Golems are themselves an
animate and independent byproduct that
naturally spawns from SCP 377 when it is
allowed to exist outside of containment
procedures the most important of these
containment procedures being that SCP
3077 must remain at a constant
temperature of well below its freezing
point point and only be stored in
containers full to capacity L its
aformentioned byproducts attempt to
breach containment the total volume of
SCP 377 within the cryogenic containment
unit equals almost
2200 L and it is believed to be the only
known quantity of the anomalous
substance in existence for the sake of
clarity in distinguishing between SCP
377 and its byproducts will be referring
to the main object contained by the
foundation as SCP 307 7 while the gooey
little guys who we know to spontaneously
split off from the source of SCP 377
will be regarded ASP
3771 as mentioned before SCP 3771
instances have been affectionately
dubbed the sugar Golems every instance
of SCP 30771 resembles an approximately
1 M tall gaunt humanoid composed of a
pure sugar derived substance commonly
known as prle and that's malas for all y
yeeha Cowboys over there in the USL if
you've ever played the classic board
game Candyland you'll have some idea of
what an individual instance of SCP 3077
looks like from the Beloved and often
remembered character of Gloppy who lives
in the Molasses swamp section of the
board and is also fittingly made out of
molasses himself yes indeed Gloppy is
truly a delight for a weary Candyland
player to meet what did you say are you
folks too young to know about Candyland
well that factoid certainly makes this
narrator feel pretty old then again I am
taking on the mannerisms and attire of
an old-fashioned Carnival Barker so I
suppose a bit of Novel Antiquity comes
with the
territory regardless the Golems are each
composed of roughly 7 lers of sweet syy
goodness and very much like everyone's
favorite character Gloppy they all lack
toine lower bodies and can all emote
through crude yet oddly endearing
vocalizations in the place of
intelligible speech while their facial
features are simplistic and Mach shapen
The Contours of concave eyes and gaping
mouth are usually present the exact
number of these eyes and mouths is
subject to variation much like the color
of the board spaces in a wonderful
wholesome family game of Candyland while
H SC SCP 30771 instance is around the
same size the body proportions and
overall shape of each instance are
rather fluid pun fly intended some
possess oversized arms or bulbous heads
While others might be conjoined to an
adjacent and sugar golum as if to show
that the two are inseparable as a pair
of best buddies or as some others might
put it a couple of
BFFs best friends for fancy frolicking
they really are quite friendly looking
aren't they and aren't they they sure
are for the only thing that these sugary
sweet SCP instances want is to be in the
company of human beings just like you
yes you who else would I be talking to
it's a hard life for this warn down
Connie let me tell you these little
sugar Golems love what they do and do
what they love but that doesn't mean
that it's time for fun in games even
though SCP 377 D1 instances want to hang
around human beings they don't tend to
stop at hey and hello or whatever those
appropriate Gittings sound like when
they are being gurgled by a dimunitive
molten sugar monster things can get out
of hand real fast just like an orange
cream popsicle melting in the sun of a
late summer's day now listen up it's
important that you pay attention to what
I say next I'm about to book learn you
about what to do if an instance of SCP
30771 enters your personal space the
results of prolonged contact with this
SCP can end badly if you're not careful
I'm not going to sugarcoat any of the
chewy details of your Grizzly fate and I
promise that it won't be a cakewalk so
don't be a nerd and listen up yes that's
right I called you a nerd you know like
nerds the candy how do you folks
seriously not know nerds they were
classic Halloween candy from the Wonka
company and they were very popular back
in the day oh what's that you say oh how
long ago was it back in the day for me
that's a bit of a root question wouldn't
you say oh won't you go ahead and knock
it off with the Wise Guy questions what
are you a pack of
Smarties I said Smarties get it just
like that ah never mind let's just move
on to the explanation of how to survive
a close encounter with this SCP that was
the main reason you came all this way to
this here educational and entertaining
video presentation after all to pick up
where I left off instances of SCP 30771
have a tendency to seek out nearby human
life the reason for doing so is
surprisingly simple and alarmingly well
alarming these sticky saine simulakra
are sely set on slithering into people's
mouths for the purposes of gaining total
control of their bodies Yes you heard
that right believe it or not the same
anomalous property which animates the
sugar Golem's prequal bodies he's
apparently capable of overriding the
human nervous system from from the
inside and that's no joke folks while
these tasty treats might sound sweet to
eat you'll be a puppet of meat from your
head to your feet if you don't complete
the tasks I intreat if an instance of
SCP 30771 attempts to enter your mouth
you must remember first and foremost to
keep your trap shut blocking it with a
mask or a similar article of clothing if
need be next you must use your limbs and
all available implements to batter the
attacking Golem away while you do your
best to keep a existance of at least
Arms Reach between yourself and the
instance it should come as a relief to
our rational people that SCP 3771
instances are severely limited in their
physical capabilities and an adult human
of average fitness can easily hold one
off if they know what to expect the
tricky part comes from the amorphous
properties of the instance's viscous
trial bodies as well as their anomolous
ability to regenerate from any physical
trauma the only way to permanent L
destroy an instance of SCP
30771 is to expose it to temperatures
above its melting point which for you
sticklers out there is approximately
176° C the most effective weapons
against SCP 30771 instances include
firebombs flamethrowers and your
run-of-the-mill convection ovens if it
is at all possible to contain the
instance within a sealed vessel such as
a large Tupperware or wooden barrel then
you ought to do whatever can to prevent
the candy creeps from running a mock
while ordinary below zero temperatures
are unable to destroy the anomalous
treal of SCP 3077 instances of SCP
30771 can effectively be slowed down or
stopped completely if you put them on
Ice whether it's the hot foot or the
cold shoulder some form of extreme
temperature should always be weaponized
when defending oneself from an SCP 30771
instance any attempt to crush or smash
an SCP PP 30771 instance will only
result in the bad bon bon breaking apart
and reforming into several more
belligerent bite-sized blighters a human
Under Siege by the sugar Golems might
find themselves quickly outnumbered if
they foolishly attempt to use a melee
weapon against the anomalies basically
it's like a more delicious version of
the popular arcade video game asteroids
no h I guess that reference was from
before even my time at any rate
instances of SCP 30771 are difficult to
destroy without access to heat or
freezing the tendency of the Molasses
menaces to increase in number is made
even worse because of the fact that any
amount of SCP 3077 outside of
containment can generate a nearly
infinite number of scp3
77-1 while even an army of SCP 30771
instances is far weaker than an
equivalent pack of hunting animals the
ability to continuously multiply and
Physiology that doesn't experience the
consequences of f fatigue means that
given enough time these sugar Golems can
Outlast any amount of human resistance
until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy
tsunami of surrender seriously scary
stuff some would say but what happens
next is the real kicker folks mind this
balo's somber Spiel if an instance of
SCP 30771 manages to Against All Odds
clamber its way into a human chatter box
and hijack the poor Sap's nervous system
the victim is immediately classified as
SCP
377-2 SCP 377-2 instances are easily
distinguished from unaffected humans on
site alone dark tendrils of SCP 3077 can
be seen visibly moving beneath the skin
and often emerge from the mouth to
crisscross the instance's face like
makeup the world's most disturbing
circus clown that's not all after the
tragic trickly transformation takes
place the movements exhibited by the
instance of SCP 307 7-2 will become
crooked and Jerky like a marionette
puppeteered by a frustrated chimpanzee
during this time the instance remains
fully conscious retaining whatever
cognitive faculties it has possessed
previous to its classification but it is
unable to attempt speech or exert
autonomy over its own actions this fun
fact was discovered by studying the EEG
recordings of several SCP 377-2
instances and is brought to you by the
United Guild of the existentially
terified if an instance of SCP 377-2
happens to wander its way into the
vicinity of any humans that haven't
succumbed to the process of consuming
SCP
30771 it will proceed to put on a juny
performance for its new found audience
this peculiar display involves clumsy
efforts at dance choreography and the
throaty singing of unsettling Eternal
Melodies that would make your annoying
cousins road trip songs sound like
they're in tune these awkward
performances continue until the audience
departs from The View of SCP 377-2
instance or the instance expires this
confirms that the point of the gesture
is to entertain as without an audience
the SCP 377-2 instance is not compelled
to make any noises of its own accord and
in general doesn't do anything other
than move around aimlessly in the event
that any number of a scp3 77-1 instances
escapes from containment and causes the
creation of SCP
377-2 members of the mobile task force
are instructed to never stray from the
line of sight of a currently performing
SCP 377-2 instance and to approach it
steadily before restraining the instance
while causing minimal harm to the body
SCP 377-2 instances can be useful for
running further tests on the anomalous
properties of SCP 3077 and there are
simple procedures that allow an instance
to be kept alive indefinitely in
containment any damage sustained during
capture can severely hamper the
efficient icy of these life sustaining
procedures the worst case scenario is
that an SCP 377-2 instance expires
before being securely contained as this
will cause the SCP 30771 instance to
emerge from its host and resume its
Relentless attack on all nearby humans
it is far easier to Simply deal with SCP
377-2 instances accordingly and this is
because SCP
377-2 only ever attempts to continue the
performance and Poss is neither the
intention nor the capacity for
retaliation if it is deemed necessary
for the effectiveness of a recapture
effort it can be permissible for the
mobile task force to allow instances of
SCP 30771 outside of containing to find
purchase within SCP
377-2 to increase the ease of
containment and lessen the risk of
foundation Personnel being affected the
performances of SCP 377-2 instances are
rarely physically intense expensive
enough to make capture too difficult but
it can be said that the Whimsical antics
of these affected humans are anything
but predictable during some rare and
special performances and if the SCP
30771 instance in control of SCP 30772
instance is feeling especially daring it
may try to show off an array of woefully
inadequate acrobatic skills front flips
that are more like belly flops back
flips that could be mistaken for pret
Falls and the sort of typ Road and trap
acts that are better left to the
imagination in lie of Prior incidents
the foundation strongly advises that if
for any reason an instance of SCP 377-2
must exist in containment it must always
be prevented from being at an altitude
of more than 6 ft from the surface of
the floor especially if any humans it
would perceive as an audience are
located directly beneath where its
performance would take place regarding
the creation of further instances of SCP
377-2 requests from any level of
foundation Personnel at site 81 or
elsewhere must be granted permission to
proceed by SCP 377s head researcher
because of the horrific implications of
what happens to the still aware human
mind while the body is affected by SCP
30771 this process is only to be
approved for use on d-class Personnel
that's right and even then in the event
that all the rigoll of the paperwork
goes through it is not acceptable to
create an instance of SCP
377-2 merely for the purpose of
providing live entertainment to fellow
researchers after all not a single one
of us should be quick to forget the
grotesque and highly regrettable
spectacle that was Dr deetz's deplorable
d-class dancers every researcher
involved with that ethical nightmare was
reprimanded severely and the colorful
novelty costumes and jangling bells that
all former d-class Personnel were made
to Weare after being reclassified to SCP
377-2 have been permanently confiscated
let the cotton candy machine and peanut
dispenser located just outside the
containment unit of SCP 3077 serve as a
Stern reminder that there's a time and
place for Monkey Shines and Tom Foolery
and sometimes yes even now and then a
highly secure Foundation facility is
neither the right place nor the right
time in case you haven't picked up on it
there are very few practical
applications of SCP 3077 due to the fact
that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of
consumption the main reason for test to
be administered on SCP 377-2 instances
is to discover if there is a safe method
of extracting an SCP 30771 instance from
the body of its host without causing the
expiration of the original human
unfortunately due to a persistent lack
of success the experiments have been
discontinued indefinitely but that just
won't do how else are we supposed to
know if these things actually taste as
good as they look I won't rest until
everyone is able to harmlessly ingest a
sugar Golem of their very own I might be
oldfashioned but to me the safe object
class isn't just a designation it's an
invitation I ought to be completely okay
doing whatever I like around a safed
object because it's safe that word
should actually mean something ding ding
darn it and I don't mean that in the
sense that the SCP Foundation uses it
meaning an anomaly that doesn't present
an active threat to containment efforts
and more importantly there aren't that
many anomalies that are also delicious
candy and I want to eat this one sorry
sorry sorry I lost my coolit there I
just have a sweet tooth and my brain is
constantly drifting back to my nostalgic
childhood memories of playing Candyland
with my family that was before they all
decided that they wanted nothing to do
with me because I became so obsessed
with dressing up like a carnival bker
that I drove away everyone who's ever
cared about me other than that my job
here at the foundation explaining
confectionary CPS is the only thing I
have left in my sad sad life some days I
feel less like Gloppy and more like a
real lord licorice in Hard Times Like
These a fellow could really use some
entertainment to cheer himself up wait
just a flee jumping moment what was that
that's the big idea how did these
escaped instances of SCP 377-2 get in
here they're all supposed to be in safe
containment a few floors down did
somebody else from the research team let
them in here because they knew I was in
costume standing in front of a pretend
Fairground set that's in pretty poor
taste don't you think pun very much
intended I should probably report it to
the head researcher that would be the
ethical reasonable thing to do then
again look at them go those are sure
some hilarious dances I'm definitely
seeing a Snappy attempt at doing the
Charleston a classic and is that one
doing the worm or is it just kind of
flopping on the floor I think one of
these instances knows about that
fortnite stuff all the kids are into
these days but I'm not sure if the human
element or the gollum that decides what
dances it knows either way this was
exactly what I needed to feel so much
better for once it feels like I'm
actually at a carnival instead of just
pretending to be at one now this is the
greatest performance I've ever seen in
all my years would you can be sure that
there have been a lot of
scp-106 is like something out of a night
terror that gray Rotting Flesh those
wide empty eyes like those of a shark
that Relentless corrosion and Decay that
follow him everywhere but what if I told
you that beneath that horrifying
exterior was a heartbreaking tragic
backstory some of our more eagley
viewers know that
scp-106 has a wide variety of potential
origin stories different events that may
have led to the old man we all know and
fear today so this is just one of
several hypothetical Back stories with
that little caveat out of the way it's
time to see if we can bring a tear to
your eye with the tragic tale of SCP
106 back in the year 2000 Dr Robert
Scranton and his wife Dr Anna Lang were
head researchers at site 120 the two of
them shared a lot of things a home a
life a shared love of Bon Joi songs but
one of the things they had in common was
a passion for experimental research the
two worked together to develop a device
called The Lang Scranton stabilizer
which was an early prototyp type of the
reality anchors used by the SCP
Foundation to this day during a round of
routine tests an earthquake unexpectedly
struck site 120 Dr Scranton was working
in reality lab a when the ground beneath
him began to rumble the LSS shook from
the activity components sliding out of
place or breaking off altogether by the
time the guards and Dr Lang arrived to
inspect the scene both Dr Scranton and
the LSS control panel were gone upon his
disappearance Dr Scranton was initially
presumed dead however 5 years 11 months
and 21 days later his whereabouts became
clear on December 23rd 2005 the LSS
control panel reappeared in site 120's
reality lab a it was covered in unknown
organic matter and rre of vomit blood
and death as Dr Anna Lang wandered into
the area against the warnings of her
colleagues she was overwhelmed with
grief and horror she choked back tears
as she accessed the control panel
retrieving the audio files left there
and realized that Dr Scranton had been
keeping a log of his time in whatever
place the disaster had sent him the
husband she had lost had in a way come
back to her but she could not see him
she could hear his voice but where was
he there was so much blood so much
unidentified organic matter it looked
like something had exploded onto the
control panel and she didn't want to
think about what or who that could have
been as Robert's wedding ring fell to
the floor Landing in the muck the
emotional strain became too much for Dr
Lang she collapsed onto the ground
hitting her head on the pavement Dr Lang
survived her fall left only with a
tender spot on her skull and a wealth of
questions she was almost too afraid to
answer but she had to find out with
answers at her fingertips she had to
know what had become of her dear Robert
so with the help of the other site 120
researchers who promised to step in when
it became too painful Dr Lang began to
go through the audio archives left
behind by her lost love in the years
since he had vanished for the first 8
Days Dr Scranton didn't speak at least
not in any recognizable words he
hyperventilated he muttered to himself
he sobbed he screamed with pure rage and
despair but he didn't say any word he
paced around the new space clawing for a
way out throwing his shoulder against
any hard surface he could in an attempt
to burst open a door but he was trapped
on his 11th day in the pocket Dimension
outside of any world he knew Dr Scranton
began to speak he reminded himself
reminded anyone who might someday listen
who he was Robert Scranton age 39 born
September 19th
1961 favorite color blue favorite song
Living on a Prayer wife Anna every day
he repeated these simple truths seeking
comfort in his memories of Anna and the
life they once shared her green eyes
their wedding day her dressed in white
shoving a piece of cake into his face
with a giddy laugh and a sparkle in her
eye he hoped that she was okay that she
had managed to escape the chaos with her
life that she had been spared a similar
fate he repeated her nickname the
password he had set for the control
panel Anna bana at this point he
realized that the machine was still
recording he called out for help desper
to see if anyone could hear him is
anyone there hello anyone anyone but of
course there was no answer why the hell
is this thing even working it can't be
working he mused what the hell he
couldn't see anything not the switches
or the knobs only the blinking of the
red recording light he was growing
hungrier and thirstier by the day and
though he knew he should be dead from
dehydration by now somehow he wasn't he
was still alive soon he found the
controls and determined he had been
trapped in this place for 2 weeks 3 days
47 hours and 58 minutes he realized at
this point that no matter how hungry he
got no matter how long he went without
water he would not die somehow in this
place his body kept going his heart
ticked along far past what should have
been his expiration date he retrieved a
small picture of Anna from his pocket
gazing at her face by The Faint glow of
the red light 2 months 4 days and 3
hours in he recorded a formal message my
name is Robert Scranton I'm a former
head researcher of site 120 a foundation
facility dedicated to studying various
reality bending scps for the purpose of
developing more advanced countermeasures
towards such threats for the last Red
Light Speak to Me 2 Months 8 Days 16
hours uh what the red light said I have
been trapped in what I believe to be an
empty pocket Dimension alone yeah alone
all alone I'm calling this place SCP um
I don't know I can't even remember where
we are screw it I don't know what's
happened in the past red light please
again 2 Months 8 Days 16 hours but no
one else is around to argue and at this
point I'm just talking into this control
panel to keep myself together I I need
to keep a record there might be some
poor chap in the future ends up like me
and if this eventually actually makes it
out maybe maybe I can help stop that
from happening it's all I have going for
me right now and I really need something
to go
for so yeah Robert Scranton documenting
a new SCP for future research purposes
that I'll have to do here we go a few
days later he added to his informal SCP
log I don't know if we could contain
wherever I am it's definitely not on
Earth to be honest I don't I don't know
where it is I I think it has something
to do with the stabilizer prototype I'll
explain that more later um okay uh yeah
wherever I am I don't think it can be
contained much as created no no that's
not the word um entered yeah entered is
better I came into this place because of
some really bad reality bending accident
then no no Robert don't be like that yet
you don't know if there's no exit yet uh
this place it's some sort of reality Gap
I think it's dark really dark as in this
little red light that shows my words are
actually being recorded is the only
visible light in this entire place I
can't even see my hands and I can barely
see the control panel here I've had to
basically use the light as a center and
remember how many steps I take and in
which direction I haven't gone past 100
yet I'm I'm too too scared to wonder if
my hair is turning white right now I
can't even see what color it is anymore
speaking of which it my head has been a
bit itchy recently if I don't
concentrate on it it's fine but I feel
this tingling all over my face I'm not
sure why I I just discovered a new
property of this place all this time
I've been thinking I might be walking on
some sort of flat ground if you will I
keep eye contact with the little red
light as far as I could see and it seems
I could walk in a straight flat path
Jesus my head is buzzing right now now I
think the adrenaline is still kicking
but if if my hypothesis is correct and
this really is some sort of reality void
then there shouldn't be anything to walk
on now that I think about it the whole
time I've been here it felt like I'm
walking but also I'm uh swimming through
something it's like I'm walking through
really thick black gel there's enough
tension to keep me on a Surface but if I
imagine myself pressing down hard enough
I I can send wait wait wait wait wait wa
wait I I think I need to test this more
I'll be back 2 months 17 days 2 hours
navigation is largely affected by
conscious impulses to travel in a
certain direction so this definitely
isn't a complete reality Gap at least
according to M and honest
theories if it were I wouldn't be able
to move at all since space wouldn't have
existed okay okay this makes a lot more
sense than it did before great great job
Robert okay you're getting there come to
think of it I should have realized that
sooner when I was able to move in a flat
plane to and from the little red it also
explains why I'm Not Dead from
dehydration or hunger yet and time
barely passes in here okay yeah so I
stood right next to little red and went
straight down okay from here on out
imagine little red as the origin of a 3D
space I went um down yeah right and then
then I was able to come back up to
little red again I've also been able to
Fly Above red movement in here is slow
like I said gel analogy but best I can
describe it as Robert became more and
more familiar with his surroundings with
the truth of where he found himself
something became clear of all the things
in this new reality he and his little
red light were the realist with time
they would begin to degrade to fall
apart he had an estimation 3 years
before he would be gone for good he had
to try and look for an end to this place
a way out out what did he have to lose
as it turned out what he had to lose was
himself he couldn't feel his legs
anymore couldn't keep a grip on his own
body he ran in one straight line for 6
months but found no Edge no end in sight
he went down for 8 months straight and
never hit bottom his sole companion was
the little red light and he continued to
talk to it as if it could ever answer
his hands began to phase into each other
the Integrity of his form beginning to
fade and Warp no matter what happened to
him he could not die his sanity began to
crumble his voice breaking into
uncontrollable sobs and hysterical
laughter whoever Robert Scranton had
been he was gone he was something else
now and who knew how long that new thing
would last for the next 25 years Dr Anna
Lang tried her best to put the thought
of her lost husband out of her head it
almost worked some days she almost
forgot that hole in her heart then one
fateful day site 120 received a deadly
visitor as cp16 reached through the back
wall of her lab dripping its horrible
rot all over the floor it grabbed for
her its touch melting her lab coat as
she tore away from its toothless grin
the singular focus and its milky eyes
the old man chased her down pushing past
a guard's bullets tearing through
everything in its path she had done
enough work on dimensional anomalies to
recognize one when she saw it and this
was one of the most destructive she had
ever encountered when it finally caught
her it said one word rad then another
one that made her eyes fill with tears
Anna Dr Robert Scranton had found a way
to escape the dead end prison he had
fallen into that gap between worlds all
it had taken was giving up his Humanity
letting that world rearrange his atams
and make him something monstrous
something that destroyed all it touched
he couldn't remember why he needed to
find Anna how he had been separated from
her for so long he could only remember
that he wanted her wanted to be with her
wanted to touch her again even as she
screamed and melted in her hands
scp-106 was once a man just like any
other man what he is now shares the
vague shape of the human he used to be
the vaguest hints of his memories but
that is where the similarities end like
the Rotting Flesh of his body might
suggest he is little more than a
shambling corpse with a ravenous
appetite for violence Dr Robert Scranton
is dead but he will never rest imagine
you were out in public and you found
yourself injured maybe you were in an
accident and couldn't move or someone
had mugged you and in the ensuing
scuffle you'd ended up getting hurt
laying on the cold filthy concrete of
the sidewalk in desperate need of help
what could be the one thing that might
make you feel even the slightest bit
better something the very sight of would
be enough to tell you everything was
going to be okay the flashing lights
drawing closer accompanied by the sound
of tires on the road and a wailing siren
all signs at an ambulance is on its way
but what if the ambulance that came to
assist you ended up making you feel far
worse than you were before and leaving
you with injuries unlike anything you'd
ever seen what if it wasn't an ambulance
at all that came to help you what if you
were found by SCP 4419 in instead Jeremy
had been having a somewhat normal day
until his accident work had been another
shift of long arduous hours spent behind
his desk 5:00 finally rolled around he
grabbed his bag and punched out if he'd
maybe left a few minutes later he might
have gotten away unscathed instead of
getting caught in the mad rush of people
leaving work Jeremy usually took the
back streets and avoided main roads as a
shortcut to get home there was less
traffic even during the rush and that
made crossing the street safer usually
he had been looking the other way when a
car came speeding down the mostly empty
side street the driver had slammed the
brakes but only too late knocking Jeremy
down winded he collapsed unable to stand
as the force of the impact had broken
his leg the driver and a few nearby
onlookers huddled around Jeremy as he
lay there with his injury suddenly the
noise of an ambulance caused the other
pedestrians to mostly disperse still
trying to catch his breath in the last
moment of his fading Consciousness the
last thing he remembered seeing were a
pair of figures they had jostled rather
aggressively through the crowd reaching
down to lift Jeremy up and shoved him
into the emergency vehicle they were
considerably rude for medical
professionals nobody around wanted to
argue with them most would even go so
far as to call them hostile but that was
nothing compared to the horror that
awaited him when he reopened his eyes
laying back on the road where he'd been
found his body had been rearranged he
barely recognized it as his own it was
like he had been turned into some
grotesque animal made using human parts
his arms and legs had been rearranged to
protrude from his torso in an unnatural
configuration what felt even worse was
that his fingers toes hands feet they
all still worked all Jeremy could do was
scream until he slipped back under a man
turned into something else entirely bad
days can happen to the best and worst of
us and sometimes those bad days can
spiral into very very bad nights Mike
had been having a night like that
earlier that day he'd lost a fair sum of
money at the races gambling was one of
his many vices as was alcohol and to
commiserate his loss Mike had hit the
bar unfortunately his already foul mood
was nudged into full-blown temper when
another Patron accidentally bumped into
him the ensuing bar fight was a complete
disoriented drunken mess of glasses
being smashed and fists thrown one
managed to connect hard with Mike's jaw
breaking it and leaving him Sat on the
sidewalk in pain cop cars had shown up
officers breaking up the Ruckus and
paramedics arriving to treat the more
badly injured patrons it was then that
two paramedics silently walked up to
Mike and grabbed him by both arms as
much as he tried to pull away from their
forceful grip his arms were covered in
bruises and cuts from the glass their
fingers dug in honing in on those
painful wounded spots so that Mike could
really feel his own injuries as they
pulled him up against his will trying to
verbally protest only hurt his jaw
further meaning he could barely call for
help as he was bundled into the back of
an ambulance doors slamming shut behind
him the next morning introduced Mike to
a whole new and far grizzli definition
of the word hangover one of the staff
who worked at the bar found him just
waiting outside when she came up to open
for business a few days later sitting
out front Mike had been left in the
gutter although it took the bartender a
moment to notice just what was wrong
with him and when she saw it in full she
screamed instead of Mike's jaw being
fixed it had been wrenched open far
wider than natural it was locked in a
permanent gaping expression the sides of
his lips sporting splits that ran all
the way into his cheeks lodged between
both rows of Mike's teeth fused to his
gums was a piece of glass too thick for
him to break to free his jaw or even
bite down on a mouthful of glass shards
and blood Cuts lining the inside of his
cheeks fragments lodged inside his
tongue all of that might have been
preferable a mercy compared to what
actually happened the glass was keeping
his mouth stretched out stopping him
from speaking like a transparent gag and
as if not being able to speak or beg for
help wasn't bad enough enough anyone
that looked through that little window
was also offered a whole other horrific
view they could see Mike's heart it had
been pulled from his chest and
reattached at the back of his throat
still beating as tears rolled down his
face he couldn't eat talk only breathe
through his nose and it hurt R and Lee
had vowed when they first got married to
love each other for Better or For Worse
in sickness and in health until death
did they part and death very nearly
almost parted them if given the choice
between dying together or suffering
through what ended up being done to them
not even their love for each other would
have made them want to stay alive the
rain was beating down on the windshield
as the couple drove home in silence
they'd had a big argument in fact it was
small in the grand scheme of their
relationship just a lover's quarrel in
that moment though it felt like the
biggest problem in the world as those
types of squabbles often do but it would
have seemed quaint compared to the Fate
that awaited both Lee and her husband
that night visibility was poor the
headlights were doing little to help
rege see through the downpour or the
dark he found it so hard to see that he
almost missed their turn quickly
wrenching the steering wheel to try and
correct the mistake regge lost control
of the car as it slid on the slippery
Road flipping sideways and rolling as
the rain continued to pour the airbags
deployed the force of being thrown
around even with her seat Bel on caused
Lee to suffer a number of broken ribs
meanwhile reg's arm was broken when the
driver's side door connected with the
ground and dented inwards as the couple
were left buckled in their seats upside
down and both crying at the pain of
their injuries they spotted the
unmistakable silhouette of an ambulance
driving through the rain towards them
they were both so relieved that neither
one of them realized they hadn't called
the emergency number yet although the
rain had long since stopped by the time
Lee woke back up the storm storm was
just beginning her head was spinning
everything was sore and aching she had
expected to be in a hospital maybe with
rege in her bed beside her both of them
recovering but alive at least pushing
herself up by her cut bloody hands Lee
could feel something heavy behind her a
weight on her back like having a ruck
sack strapped to her only it was harder
to move almost the same mass as a person
slowly looking over her shoulder
Lee screamed when she saw the Flesh of
her back had been fused to reges their
skin melted and stuck together like
candle wax each of them unable to pull
away without the pain of feeling like
they were being ripped apart to make
matters worse Lee had undergone other
modifications talk about in sickness or
health living alone Rodney was
relatively content with his life since
retiring he'd been able to spend his
Twilight years appreciating the the
little things spending most of his time
out in the garden tending to his flowers
and occasionally enjoying the company of
his adult son unfortunately with old age
Comes The increased risk of health
problems and to say Rodney had himself
more than his fair share of heart
difficulties or a bum ticker as he
called it was an understatement while
out in his garden Rodney suffered a
violent heart attack and collapsed
wheezing and struggling to breathe
luckily his son Keith was in the house
at the time he witnessed his elderly
father dropped to the ground and ran out
to help him calling for an ambulance as
he tried to calm Rodney down the
Emergency Services seemed to arrive much
quicker than Keith had been expecting a
pair of paramedics rushing through the
house to lift his dad away what struck
him as strange was neither one would
tell Keith which hospital they were
taking his dad to and they outright
refused to let him ride in the back of
the ambulance to keep Rodney lucid and
reassure him that he was in safe hands
when Keith went to climb into the back
one of the paramedics pushed him by the
chest with enough strength to knock him
over as he pulled himself off the
concrete the rear door slammed shut and
the ambulance sped away to God knows
where with Rodney in the back after a
few days of hearing nothing Keith had
already tirelessly been calling every
hospital in the area to ask if his dad
had been admitted none of them had seen
Rodney and his worried son had just been
about to call the police to file missing
person's report when his elderly father
appeared on the doorstep immediately
Keith drove his dad to the Emergen room
trying to explain what had happened with
the strange ambulance while the hospital
maintained that it wasn't one of theirs
they admitted Rodney and gave him a full
examination only to find something that
would turn the stomachs of the world's
most seasoned doctors Rodney had more
than one heart someone had given him not
just a spare but 11 additional Hearts
they were stuffed between his natural
organs like too many books squeezed
together on a shelf and not one of them
was beating they were causing far more
harm than good Rodney's insides were
riddled with these foreign bodies that
were stopping his lungs from fully
inflating resting on his stomach and
Wrecking Havoc with his bodily functions
upon discovery of these extra Hearts
Rodney was rushed into the operating
theater with his son nervously pacing in
the corridor outside sadly a doctor
would soon appear to tell Keith that the
moment the surgeons removed one of the
additional Hearts Rodney's old bu ticker
had finally given out sometimes as sad
as it may be to reconcile with tragedy
strikes one night a fire broke out in a
crowded bar leading to a whole host of
people suffering severe burns and
requiring urgent medical attention what
they received instead was far more
brutal and barbaric Joyce had been in
the bar when the alarm started to ring
nobody knew what had started it only
that they needed to evacuate but it
didn't take the Flames long to reach the
alcohol behind the bar and before along
the whole place was Ablaze everyone
panicking and barging past each other to
get out once free of the Searing heat
swapping it for the biting cold of the
night air the commotion didn't seem to
end someone near her pointed to an
ambulance that had just arrived and a
Duo of paramedics that were manhandling
some of the more badly burned bar
patrons forcing them into the back of
their vehicle along with about six
others Joyce marched up as the group
protested how the injured drinkers were
being treated when the paramedics
refused to stop things got uglier the
ensuing brawl left Joyce and the other
six people with skull fractures rather
than just leave them behind the
paramedics grabbed them too Joyce was
pushed into an already overcrowded
ambulance there were 26 people crammed
in their total including her 19 of them
had nasty burns on their skin wounds
that were only made worse by being
packed together in such a tight space
and jostled around as the ambulance
drove away there were no sign of the
missing 26 bar patrons for around a week
the families of those that had
disappeared after the fire urged the
police to keep searching for them with
no bodies recovered at the scene by
firefighters nobody had a clue where the
group had gone Joyce's partner Al even
printed off missing flyers and handed
them out to anyone who would take them
they also happened to be the caretaker
of a local community center and after
another day of worrying tirelessly about
Joyce Al moped back there to clean and
lock the place up what they found
waiting for them was like something out
of an old old horror Bee movie or
something found in the deepest parts of
the ocean filling one of the rooms of
the community center was a huge watery
Mass it wasn't pure liquid although Al
first mistook it as the result of a
leaking pipe the mass was fluid it
twitched and shivered whenever they
reached out to touch it almost like a
living thing or what was left of a few
living things say 26 bar patrons melted
down and reduced to a collective liquid
mass
now you'd think having an accident out
in public would be as bad as things got
but that's nothing compared to being
injured in the line of duty right in the
middle of a war zone that's what
happened to private Jackson while he and
his Squad were out on a routine Patrol
in Afghanistan a group of enemy
insurgents ambushed the United States's
soldiers during the ensuing firefight
private Jackson sustained a severe
gunshot wound leaving him bleeding out
his comrades had called for a medical
evacuation and were expecting a US Army
helicopter to arrive at any moment what
none of them had expected was a City
ambulance driving towards them across
the battlefield as if it was the most
normal site on Earth already suspicious
of the approaching vehicle private
Jackson's fellow teammates raised their
weapons at the approaching paramedics
despite the solders demands for them to
identify themselves neither one of the
ambulance attendants seemed to pay them
much mind grabbing private Jackson and
dragging the wounded soldier towards the
vehicle he called to the rest of his his
Squad wanting to be let go having no
idea where he was about to be taken or
why the commanding officer barked at the
pair of EMTs warning if they didn't
release private Jackson then his men
would open fire still the paramedics
didn't seem to be listening just as they
threw Jackson into their ambulance and
climbed into the cab at the front the
other soldiers opened fire squeezing
their triggers bullets were spat from
their weapons riddling the metal sides
of the vehicle as it began to drive away
siren blaring and lights flashing every
shot that connected with the ambulance
seemed to cause it to leak a viscous
black fluid like an oil but despite this
it did little to deter the ambulance
from driving away with Jackson captive
in the back after being successfully
extracted from the battlefield the
remainder of the squad were airlifted
back to safety arriving back at their
nearby base the following day each one
of them were solemnly silent all of them
were confused as to how an ambulance had
even appeared in the desert out of
nowhere and disappeared Without a Trace
but even more so they were concerned for
the life of their kidnapped comrade
however they wouldn't have to wait long
as arriving at their Barracks revealed
the Grim grotesque fate of Private
Johnson he was on the walls as in all
over the walls his body had been
dissolved somehow broken down into
little more than a thin bloody paste
that had now been smeared over the
interior of the barracks looking out at
his former Squad from The liquefied
Remains was a single human eyeball
private Jackson's eye wide with horror
at what had been done to him SCP 4419
known to some by the nickname of the
butcher's Chariot is still out there at
present it is unknown who or indeed what
performs the horrific mutilations on its
victims or even why it could be that SCP
4419 if it has a Consciousness could be
trying to help those it abducts but
lacks the correct medical understanding
of how to do so then again again it
could simply just be cruel torturing and
deforming people unfortunate enough to
need emergency medical attention given
how sporadically this anomalous
ambulance can appear and disappear at
the sight of any medical emergency
anywhere on the planet there's little
the foundation can do other than stay
vigilant and pick up SCP 4419 patients
after it has mutilated them or rather
they can pick up whatever's left of
their victims can a thought be
infectious is it possible that
transferring an idea can happen as
easily as catching the common cold
someone gets it then transmits it to
another person who then passes it on to
someone else and so on imagine for a
moment that information is a disease we
can't see information or feel it we can
read it in books or on the internet but
actually seeing it or feeling it inside
our heads is impossible so what if
something could taint the information we
absorb use it to slip its way undetected
into your your mind then pass from you
to your friends your family your
co-workers how would you know it was
there and how could you prevented from
getting into your head perhaps it's time
you were introduced to SCP 3002 over its
many years of studying and containing
anomalous beings and entities the SCP
Foundation has encountered a number of
creatures with mimetic abilities if you
unfamiliar with the term mimic usually
refers to data or information that has
been manipulated in in order to
influence or subconsciously change a
person's Behavior this can take any form
from text and images to spoken phrases
and other audio for example a form of
mimetic influence we have all
experienced at some point is product
placement if you ever watched a
character in a movie or on TV using a
certain product then that may have made
you decide that you want to buy that
same product for yourself that idea was
planted in your head by something you
saw and had a subliminal influence
fluence on your behavior SCP 3002 is one
such entity that uses mimetic stimuli
for its own nefarious purposes some
anomalies like SCP 2440 use mimetic
information to spread knowledge of
themselves among human beings getting
stronger the more people learn about it
SCP 3002 on the other hand is
information this entity is a thought a
living sentient thought with a number of
abilities that allow it to influence the
minds of human beings it is hard to
picture a thought let alone one that is
alive since we can't see information the
idea of something so abstract having a
tangible form boggles the Mind SCP 3002
is capable of shape-shifting and while
it does not possess its own consistent
shape the entity is able to transform
itself into the form of any piece of
information it chooses existing is pure
information means that it is intangible
to any beings that possess physical
bodies but what makes SCP 30002 a threat
to everyone at the foundation and earn
this entity its ker classification is
its power to manipulate a person's mind
or memories allowing SCP 3002 to
directly enter human Minds moving at the
speed that thoughts can travel through
the brain this entity is almost
impossible to kill or kept contained SCP
3002 can spread like a sickness through
a human population attacking new and
taking control of its victims according
to the foundation's research there's is
only one way to remove the influence of
SCP 3002 anyone that comes under the
control of this entity has to undergo
complex intricate and risky brain
surgery in order to physically remove
the entity from their minds however the
foundation considers this method to be
impractical timec consuming cost
ineffective and is rendered utterly
pointless if SCP 3002 has infected too
much of a subject's mind so instead in
order to prevent the spread of SCP 3002
influence all Foundation Personnel are
instructed to terminate any person
contaminated by this living thought this
order is extended to that individual's
family friends colleagues and even
acquaintances given that SCP 3002 can
take the form of any information it
chooses written words a sound even a
telepathic signal anyone even remotely
linked to someone the enti infects has
to be destroyed to stop any potential
spread if you or anyone you knew were to
come into contact with SCP 32 The Entity
would be able to take control of your
entire Consciousness all your memories
would be ripe for the entity's picking
SCP 3002 is able to sift through your
temporal lobe where memories are stored
and can not only destroy and delete an
infected person's memories but can also
create false memories to replace them
and all the while you would be
completely completely unaware that this
was happening to you stripped of all
your natural survival instincts while
SCP 3002 runs riot in your brain there
is currently no known limit to how much
of someone's mind SCP 3002 is able to
mimic rewrite alter or remove when the
entity Alters one of your memories that
memory will become an additional
instance of SCP 3002 in other words it
can implant itself in every moment of
your life making itself a part of
everything you remember about your own
personal past and even the parts you
can't once SCP 3002 has spread itself to
every piece of information stored inside
your brain the next stage of infection
begins and SCP 3002 is able to take full
control of a person's body much like
before this could be happening to you
without you ever being consciously aware
of it usually this doesn't come to much
and infected victims will carry on their
day-to-day lives acting no different to
how how they would normally that is
until SCP 3002 detects a new Target that
hasn't been infected yet when this
happens any people previously exposed to
SCP 3002 will collectively seek out the
uncontaminated individual capturing them
once this happens SCP 3002 is infected
Army will force their new victim to join
them the SCP Foundation considers SCP
3002 to be extremely hostile and a major
threat to their organization and the
World At Large due to SCP 3002 being
uncontainable and able to infinitely
adapt it has evaded capture or
termination for a considerable length of
time having the ability to spread among
human beings via the information we
share with each other speech texts
emails phone calls any information at
all means that potentially any and all
information could contain as SCP
3002 according to calculations of the
foundation's top researchers 7 98% of
humanity may be under the influence of
SCP 3002 without any awareness that they
have been infected while dangerous and
Unstoppable SCP 3002 doesn't operate
purely on Instinct it doesn't infect as
many Minds as it can just because it
knows no other way everything that SCP
3002 does is a premeditated calculated
decision with one nefarious intention
one goal to destroy the SC P Foundation
From the Inside Out by killing or
infecting every member of personnel
Believe It or Not SCP 3002 didn't begin
life as a sentient infectious thought in
fact SCP 3002 was once a person a
regular human being like you or I she
even had a name Lily Vela it is widely
believed that Lily Vela became what we
now know as SCP 3002 due to the actions
of the foundation itself since becoming
SCP 3002 Lily seems to have been
searching for any information she can
find regarding a highly secret operation
conducted by the SCP Foundation known as
project lefy as well as this she appears
to have an interest in a number of
foundation research facilities including
site e and an off thee books facility
located in Ukraine's yanin National Park
this is potentially where SCP 3002 was
first created if any of this is to be
believed then would certainly explain
SCP 3002 is noticeable aggression
towards the foundation and its attempts
to infect its personnel as an act of
Revenge after the project that turned
Lily into a living thought SCP 3002 was
later encountered by the foundation in
its current form in South Rock
Penitentiary this prison located near
Lafayette Indiana was first visited by
one Dr darl Lloyd one of the SCP
foundation's researchers the prison
psychiatrist a woman named Dr Suzanne
Fairbank was the first to notice the
effects of SCP 3002 contamination on a
number of South Rock penitentiary's
inmates during sessions with her several
of these prisoners had mentioned an
identical memory to Dr Fairbank the
description of the memory from each of
the inmates followed the same structure
The Prisoner remembered taking a long
walk through a forest with their best
friend at the time this detail the best
friend is most likely SCP 3002 herself
imitating a figure from each inmate's
own childhood memories at some point in
this false shared memory all the
prisoners Rec called having an argument
with their friend it was later learned
that the figure was Lily Vela
approaching infected individuals in
their memories to ask them questions
about the project that had turned her
into SCP
3002 often demanding to know what do you
know about me or has the project
finished the foundation began to
investigate this bizarre instance of
shared anomaly memory after Dr Suzanne
Fairbank shared her findings on an
internet Message Board describing what
she had witnessed to other psychology
experts at first Dr Lloyd the
foundation's researcher sent to South
Rock to gather more information labeled
the situation as low priority research
given SCP 3 2002's ability to adapt and
take the form of any information it was
able to avoid immediate detection by the
SCP Foundation and the full extent of
Lily's abilities remained hidden Dr
Lloyd originally classified SC SCP 3002
as safe believing it was a little more
than a shared childhood memory that the
South Rock inmates had described at
first those that had been infected with
this Collective memory were able to
recount it with perfect accuracy but as
Dr lyd continued to interview and test
the affected inmates the details became
scarier and the memory became less and
less defined the further the SCP
Foundation looked into it perhaps Lily
recognized the foundation's presence and
and remembered that they were the ones
responsible for turning her into a
sentient mimetic entity without physical
form and started hiding her tracks maybe
she was biting herself time hiding
herself away in the minds of the
infected prisoners until the time was
right little did Dr Lloyd realize at the
time just how far SC SCP 3002 influence
had already spread Lily wasn't just in
the inmates heads but almost all of the
prison staff too who were now spreading
her further and further without even
even realizing it thinking that SC SCP
3002 would be easy to contain Dr Lloyd
have the foundation administer andmetics
to all the infected inmates amnestics
are memory altering drugs that the SCP
Foundation uses to prevent any
information about scps becoming known to
the public when dealing with mimetic
anomalies like SCP 3002 or SCP 2440
amnestics can be particularly useful in
removing a person's memories about a
mtic SCP Dr Lloyd hoped that this would
be the case at South Rock still thinking
as SCP 3002 was nothing more than an
anomalous shared memory that could be
removed however removing the false
memory that Lily had implanted in the
prisoners would not remove her from all
their other memories additionally one of
the infected inmates was not given
amnestics and was brought back to the
foundation for observation from there
SCP 3002 influence had been able to
spread like a sickness through the ranks
of the foundation's own personel
without their knowledge or detection
every person whose mind SCP 3002 is able
to reach becomes an unwitting carrier
for the Infectious living thought it is
unknown exactly how many of the SCP
foundation's members are under the
control of SCP 3002 granting Lily access
to the wealth of secret information and
plans that the foundation keeps hidden
it doesn't matter what level of
clearance someone would need to view it
if it's information it's another way for
SCP 3 2 to spread and information as we
know can take any form be it a written
file a spoken conversation or even an
informative YouTube video now tell me
again about the time that we took a walk
together in the forest okay guys so to
wrap this video up I really don't think
this cursed episode of this show was
real it's obviously just a really good
scary fan animation and the fact that
the creators behind it didn't come out
and claim ownership of it sooner
allowing it to be reposted and
re-uploaded so many times is really what
got people thinking was legit that being
said it's still a good attempt at what a
cursed Lost episode would look like so
shout out to those animators man anyway
I've been the goat hell holder 98 be
sure to like this video subscribe to my
channel down below and hey if you know
about any more lost media you want me to
cover leave it in the comments I'll
check it out now be sure to follow my
socials at HH holder 98 I go live most
days and post updates about new videos
on my story so go check it out all right
until then I'll see you somewhere down
the line the moment his finger pushed
the the button to stop the camera
recording the practiced false smile
dropped from Holden's face it was hard
not to feel down after he'd finished
filming a new video not thanks to any
post creativity slump but the more
depressing knowledge of just how much of
an uphill battle this whole thing was it
felt like yesterday when Holden had
first gotten into the creepier side of
the internet he never ventured into
anything illicit or outright illegal
mind you but there was a distinct corner
of the web that had pulled him in when
he was still at school and just starting
to spend more time online this part of
the internet was filled with scary
stories that were mostly fake or made up
for likes but that could have been real
there were unsettling animations short
clips that were handdrawn to give people
the creeps and keep them up at night not
to mention a whole Archive of Public
Safety announcement videos terrifying
workplace and road safety warnings that
used to be broadcast on TV and were as
petrifying than the most acclaimed
horror movies speaking of things that
were broadcast youv that had gradually
become Holden's specialty one of his
friends had sent him the link to a
fictional account of someone who had
supposedly uncovered an unaired episode
of a Saturday morning kids cartoon or so
this person claimed anyway they went on
to describe bizarre imagery so intense
and terrifying that it was unbefitting
of a show for children then the person
who made the original post explained how
they got into contact with the show's
creators via email to ask them about
this cursed episode The showrunner
responded stating that the episode the
poster had allegedly seen didn't even
exist to Holden it didn't matter if the
story was real or not that wasn't the
point what was far more important was
that it felt real to him it was
plausible even possible that there were
pieces of media out there in the world
that had never seen the light of day
episodes of TV shows or entire movies
that were so wild and out there that
they could have been banned and buried
long before the dawn of the the internet
wherein there was a record of everything
and nothing was ever really lost the
idea of uncovering those lost pieces of
media became Holden's primary hobby he'd
come home from school throw his backpack
onto his bed and then sit in front of
his computer for hours without even
changing out of the clothes he had been
wearing all day in class but all the
time he spent trolling through form
threads following and messaging
collectors on social media listening to
theories and coming up with his own
eventually it began to encroach on other
things much to his mom's disappointment
Holden's grades took a rapid decline it
wasn't long before he was failing his
classes bad enough to not make the cut
to continue on at school but as much as
it upset his mother Holden really didn't
mind he was already thinking Way Beyond
high school and he knew he didn't need
grades to be able to do the one thing he
wanted to do with his life Holden set up
his own Channel with a plan to start
uploading videos under his new online
alter ego and before long hell holder 98
was born he centered his whole internet
Persona around lost media discussing
which popular rumors were true and which
were fictionalized for likes and clicks
it started out with a few discussion
videos where he would simply sit in his
bedroom a camcorder opposite him as he
spoke but before long Holden was adding
more and more flare to his content
learning how to edit on his computer
adding Clips or screenshots he could
find of supposed Lost TV episodes to
give his videos some credibility a very
necessary quality when trying to
determine if certain things were real or
not each video he finished he had
another two topics to a list of ideas he
kept planning to just perpetually churn
out content until he eventually had a
huge hit that went viral although the
one thing he didn't realize until it was
perhaps too late was that social media
success didn't happen overnight in fact
it didn't happen over many many nights
either no matter how often Holden
promoted his channel on his social media
profiles or how many new videos he
uploaded he couldn't seem to get any to
land well and get boosted by the
algorithm at least that's one of the
things he attributed the problem to he
pointed the finger of blame at anything
that he could one day it was that the
algorithm was suppressing his channel
and boosting others who had already got
more subscribers the next it might be
his slow internet connection had led to
one of his videos going live at a time
when the site had low traffic the one
possibility that Holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too Niche but that the days
of the internet's interest in Lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to Garner
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to hell holder
98 the only number that seemed to be at
all increasing was the number of videos
he had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to Impossible every now and then he
would post on forms asking for advice or
if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger followings those posts were
often met with a slew of apathetic sned
responses or comments telling Holden to
just quote make better cont content as
if that was solid specific advice on top
of that his mom had outright refused to
support her son's chosen career path
citing his failure at school as the main
reason speaking of any friends Holden
previously had at school had all moved
away in the years since going off to
pursue college and other higher
education some were even starting their
new and exciting professions the old
saying said it's Lonely at the Top but
Holden was just as lonely down at the
bottom posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting
into an empty void with no one around to
hear the few people Holden did still
consider his friends were all as quicly
online as he was most of them fellow
lost media collectors after interacting
with them in the common threads of
various forums the handful of
like-minded guys were as close as Holden
had to people actively supporting his
channel the collectors would usually
give him pointers or topics to discuss
in videos and contributing to the
singled digigit view count underneath
his uploads although to him it wasn't
nearly enough he didn't want just his
friends to see his videos he wanted an
audience a fan base of his own it was
late the light of the computer monitor
Illuminating the dark of Holden's
bedroom punched over his desk he was
clicking and dragging clips into the
timeline of a video project trimming
them down to make the whole thing better
paced snipping out bad takes where he
stumbled over his words or misspoke it
was while editing that Holden noticed
another screen lighting up on his desk
accompanied by a vibration his phone he
reached for it seeing a notification
popped up on the lock screen it was from
goth one of the Lost media collectors
and it read dude urgent found something
that you can make a video on hold inside
it was late and it was already focused
on editing this current video tonight if
he got it finished then he could go to
sleep what do you know about the deathly
videotape goth asked in a second message
before Holden even had a chance to open
it first the what he replied bluntly
before sending another text saying can't
this wait until the morning I'm trying
to edit if you don't act fast it'll be
gone forever came the response only a
second later followed by a link
lethargically hold and tap the hyperlink
goth had sent his phone opening up its
browser and displaying the web page it
was a buy and sell website one of those
places where people offloaded junk they
didn't want anymore to strangers for a
bit of extra cash the page in question
showed a few grainy photos taken on a
phone of a small rectangular object in
someone's hand what is that Holden asked
it's a videotape Bon head go fired back
although they'd never met in person
Holden always got the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand Sony color collection 60 to
90minut mini DV videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what Holden asked
in another text look there have been
rumors for ages about something called
The Deathly videotape go replied in a
series of Rapid Fire messages it used to
be all the AG on a lot of old lost media
forums the real nasty ones before they
got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
VCR and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape Holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with goth read the
item description he answered Holden's
eyes scanned down the page finding a
short message from the seller to anyone
interested I'm giving this old Mini DV
tape away I don't know where I got it or
why I watched it but I wish I hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that I've seen what's on it let me make
this clear I am not selling this tape
I'm giving it away free of charge I hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous Holden texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading goth
responded underneath the item
description was an another note that the
seller had written please note I am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can I mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in Holden's Hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from Ghost you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape Holden looks back at the
address double-checking where it was at
most it take a quick walk there and back
he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as go said it was then owning it
would mean Holden would be the only one
who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before Holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how it could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the eame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that Holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
Holden Square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand scalled note I know you'll
ignore me if I tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old outmoded
recording format and convert the footage
to digital so he could include it in his
video Holden had retrieved his mom's old
VHS player from the attic wiping the
thick layer of dust off of it it took a
while for him to get everything ready to
go not just finding the right adapters
and cables to hook the VCR up to his TV
as well as linking that to his computer
plus angling his camera right and making
sure the ring light he bought for
filming was putting enough focus on his
face after the substantial prep Holden
took a deep breath summoning up the foe
excitement and Stage smile before he hit
the record button on his camera what's
up guys it's hell holder 98 here now
today I've got a real treat for you all
so my friend G shout out to him told me
that a while ago there was talk about
something called The Deathly video tape
we found a mini DV tape that we think
might be that very same tape so we're
going to watch it and see if it's legit
dropping his Persona as his face turned
away from the camera Holden punched the
play button on the VHS player his eyes
glued to the TV screen as the camera's
lens was fixated on him okay nothing so
far he observed met with nothing but a
blank black screen suddenly after 12
seconds of nothing the playback started
instantly and Holden started relaying at
what he was seeing on the tape to the
camera there was no sound either because
the recording on the video tape was
filmed at the that way or Holden hadn't
properly figured out how to hook it up
to the VHS the video itself showed a
recording of Sesame Street Live and for
the most part just seemed pretty
underwhelming characters were up on
stage their puppeteers managing to stay
out of sight as they entertained their
young audience after 2 and 1/2 minutes
Holden was starting to feel like he'd
gone to all this effort over what seemed
to just be someone's old unwanted home
video just as he was considering turning
off the camera and throwing the
videotape in the trash at almost the
3-minute mark Mark something weird
started happening on the stage the actor
playing one of the bigger characters
seemed to be having some trouble
instantly trying to pull off his
cumbersome costume much to the distress
of the kids in the audience looking on
in horror but it wasn't just the
illusion that had been broken the actor
was trying to get out of his costume
because he was choking he dropped to his
knees on stage clawing at his own throat
before Finally Falling face down totally
still
asphyxiated dead over the next almost 20
seconds the same thing started happening
to another three of the characters on
stage all of them violently choking
while the children in the audience
screamed and cried silently on the
inaudible tape then at 3 and 1/2 minutes
the video cut out Holden was unsure how
to react at first a little creeped out
only to be somewhat amused he played it
down for the camera remarking that the
video seemed tame compared to some of
the more graphic fake content he'd seen
but the whole time even after raing
recording sitting awake all night to
edit his reaction video blurring out the
parts that would break the terms of
service he had no idea what he'd seen
was actually real or not finishing the
final edit just as the sun was coming up
Holden hit upload and crawled into bed
while his video was uploaded the buzz of
a text message from goth awoke him dude
I told you this video was going to make
it big without even replying Holden
booted up his computer and open the page
for his newly uploaded video The View
count was already in the thousands and
climbing comments pouring in underneath
mostly from people debating whether or
not the contents of the tape had been
faked Holden punched the air and
excitement he'd finally done it but as
the video kept playing he heard a
wretching sound coming from the
computer's speakers he turned to look
back at his earlier self filmed only the
night before except what he was seeing
play out on screen now wasn't what he
remembered happening last night it
couldn't have because the Holden in that
video was choking that wasn't possible
he was alive and watching his own video
right now but somehow the footage was
shown him dying his Airway blocked face
turning red then blue as tears streamed
down his cheeks in the video hell holder
98 fell down dead from asphixiation and
watching it made Holden feel sick to
make matters worse none of the comments
under the video seem to have witnessed
the same ending Holden even texts go to
ask if the same thing had happened but
he described the ending exactly as
Holden remembered filming it but
afterwards it didn't stop stop happening
everything he watched ended the same
every clip online every TV show every
movie Holden couldn't even read a book
without some characters fictional or
otherwise Keeling over and choking to
death just like the characters on the
tape he barely had time to acknowledge
the hits his reaction to the deathly
videotape we getting he was too busy
trying to figure out why he couldn't
stop seeing people dying the exact same
way even himself when he watched back
his old hell holder 98 videos reacting
to to the deathly videotape garnered a
respectable 3 million views but hell
holder 98 never uploaded again
afterwards his channel went silent
remembered only as a one hit wonder
until the video and the entire Channel
were taken down Holden was never
reported missing the foundation made
sure of that when they came by to
collect SCP 583 and placed the videotape
into containment now if you're still in
the mood for some lost media that you
might not want to watch alone then you
should go and check out SCP 7 1933
season opener or if you like your TV
game shows to be a little too real and a
lot deadlier why not grab the remote and
hit play on SCP 024 the announcer